Die Zeit ist hier.
Wir müssen drückend um.
Ich höre dich hier. Hast du gesagt, du hörst mich nicht? Hab ich gesagt, du sollst die Musik schon abfahren?
Ich hab das gesagt.
Aber wann?
Eben.
Achso. Aber hatten wir nicht gesagt, immer wenn Konstanze Musik abfährt, dann muss Konstanze vorher anmoderieren.
Ja, ich dachte, weil du schon so ein bisschen beschäftigt warst.
Achso, da hast du gedacht, ihr unterstützt mich mal in der Suche nach dem Eingangssignal. Herzlich willkommen zur Chaosradio-Lounge 122. Heute ist dabei L.Lady Konstanze. Der Frank. Guten Tag. Ich dachte, du sagst jetzt nichts. Das Thema heute ist der Bundestrojaner. Und wie immer, wenn so ein Ding irgendwie nur, also das Thema eines Chaosradios nur aus einem einzigen Wort besteht, stelle ich die Frage, meint ihr das schon, das reicht für drei Stunden? Warte mal. Stimmt.
Na ja, es hat sich auch einfach eine ziemlich breite Debatte in den letzten Wochen gebildet. Da können wir eine Menge drüber reden.
Du könntest vor allen Dingen eine Menge direkt ins Mikrofon sprechen. Das wäre super. Du kannst jetzt auch so ein bisschen drehen, dass du trotzdem noch in die Richtung gucken kannst, in die du bisher geguckt hast. So, Thorsten, komm mal vom Klavier weg, sag mal.
Ja, also ich denke wir können hier heute nicht nur drüber reden, wir können auch drüber ranten und ja, denken wir auch, dass da genug Leute daraus zuhören, die hier anrufen und uns auch fleißig was erzählen.
Genau, und wir schenken natürlich Cocktails aus. Eigentlich bräuchten wir noch so eine Schubidou Showtreppe.
Nee, Schubidou Showtreppe ist, die Musik bleibt mehr so mellow.
Ja, das möchte man doch jetzt eigentlich, der sich um Verstand gesoffen hat.
Achso, ich dachte du wolltest dein Röckchen anziehen und den...
Nein, da muss jetzt ein großer Entertainer die Showtreppe runterkommen und sagen, guten Abend.
Wir reden trotzdem mal über den Bundestrojaner heute.
Ich singe derweil ein bisschen im Hintergrund.
Genau, sing ein bisschen im Hintergrund, Holgi. Gib dem mal ein Bier, bitte. Da steht irgendwas von nicht essen, nicht trinken, nicht rauchen, keine Drogen, Mobiltelefon aus, Fenster nicht öffnen, nicht denken und...
Da drunter steht noch ein Klein mit Cooley Fresse halten.
Ja, klare Dienstanweisung ist da draußen vor, oder?
Können wir jetzt mal über den Bundestrojaner reden, wenn es hier schon kein Bier gibt?
Also der Bundestrojaner, worum geht es da? Im Kern geht es darum, dass die Sicherheitsbehörden, nachdem sie die Kryptodebatte verloren haben, also ursprünglich wollten sie ja gerne in unsere Verschlüsseln-Systeme reinschauen können, beziehungsweise eine Pflicht dazu haben, für den Bürger seinen Schlüssel zu hinterlegen oder zu übergeben, wenn die Ermittlungsbehörden den haben wollen. Das haben sie ja verloren. Es gab dann die Leitlinien, beziehungsweise die Eckpfeiler deutscher Kryptopolitik, die darauf hinauslaufen, dass jeder hier verschlüsseln kann, so wie er will und ihm niemand da reinreden kann. Und so in den paar Jahren, seitdem, hatten die Ermittlungsbehörden nach einer Aussage nicht so richtig viele Probleme mit verschlüsselten Festplatten oder verschlüsselten Kommunikationsmedien.
Weil es keiner benutzt hat.
Weil es relativ wenig Leute benutzt haben. Mittlerweile wird es halt immer mehr Standard. So, Vista kommt jetzt irgendwie zumindest in der nicht-Kindergarten-Version schon mit einer Festplattenverschlüsselung. Und Festplattenverschlüsselungsprogramme sind billig geworden. Email-Verschlüsselung sind die meisten Email-Client integriert und so weiter. Also es heißt, der Grad an Normalverschlüsselung nutzt einfach zu. Und deswegen haben sie da mittlerweile so langsam Probleme. Mir hat vor zwei Jahren mal ein relativ hochrangiger Mitarbeiter eines Landeskriminalamts erzählt, dass sie genau das, was sie jetzt tun, nämlich zu versuchen, das Recht zu bekommen, auf den Computer des Benutzers einsteigen zu dürfen, um da die Daten zu kriegen, bevor sie oder wenn sie nicht verschlüsselt sind, dass genau das ihr Plan ist. Also dass sie das sozusagen als letzte Möglichkeit sehen, bei wie sie halt immer so schön sagen, Schwerstkriminalität oder dergleichen Dinge mehr, Terrorismus ist ja immer so ein beliebtes Schlagwort dabei, an die Informationen zu kommen, die halt auf den Computern von irgendwelchen Übeltätern gespeichert sind. Und da sie halt bei Beschlagnahme von Computern, so sagen sie zumindest häufiger, nicht so viel Glück haben, wollen sie halt jetzt online darauf gucken. Also das ist sozusagen der Hintergrund. Es entstand da relativ schnell das Schlagwort von Bundestrojaner, also dem trojanischen Pferd, das von Staatswegen halt auf den Computer von Verdächtigen geschmuggelt wird. Torsten, vielleicht kannst du kurz mal Trojaner erklären, was damit genau gemeint ist?
Also ich meine, an Sachen Computer Trojaner, da gibt es natürlich, da ist der Fantasie keine Grenzen gesetzt. Da kann man nicht sagen, da fängt die Grenze an, da fängt Trojaner an oder so. Grundsätzlich bezeichnet man mit so einem Trojanern eben Software, die man sich unwissentlich installiert, das heißt, man installiert sich eventuell irgendein neues Spiel und denkt, man kann das jetzt schön spielen. In Wirklichkeit ist es ein Trojaner, weil das kann außer dieses Spiel anzuzeigen, auch noch ein paar Sachen mehr, zum Beispiel im Hintertüren aufreißen für Angreifer oder ja, Schnüffler wie auch immer. Das mal ganz grob gesagt, man glaubt sich etwas zu installieren, was man kennt. Trojaner kommen halt auch auf die Platte, wenn man die nicht wissentlich installiert, zum Beispiel einfach durch schlecht ausgebildete Menschen, die E-Mail-Anhänge ausführen und so weiter oder irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken in der Software, die benutzt wird im Betriebssystem, im Webbrowser, dass es eben soweit kommt, dass Software aus dem Netz runtergeladen wird und sich heimlich unbemerkt installiert.
Also der Begriff kommt ja vom trojanischen Pferd aus der griechischen Sage. Also die Geschichte war...
Wir müssten aber die Spartaner gewesen, wenn die Troja belagert haben.
Genau, ich wollte Troja erobern und hatte ihnen halt ein Holzpferd voller Soldaten vor die Stadt gestellt. Sie waren so neugierig, dass sie es irgendwie reingeholt haben. Und dann sind nachts die Soldaten rausgesprungen und haben die Tore aufgemacht. Also sozusagen der Begriff wird verwendet für etwas, was anders aussieht, als das sein eigentlicher Inhalt ist.
Und eigentlich weicht der Begriff Computer Trojaner in diesem Fall ja auch ganz konkret davon ab, weil die hatten damals ja...
Es waren die Griechen.
Die Griechen.
Ach, die Spartaner waren ja schon bei 300 draufgegangen.
Würde ich mich jetzt auf noch dünneres Eis fürgeben als vorhin, wenn ich da jetzt noch mit diskutieren würde. Aber ich glaube, es war so, ja.
Anyway, wir haben also mit einem Computerprogramm zu tun, was irgendwie mehr Dinge tut, als es eigentlich tun sollte.
Aber unbemerkt im Gegensatz zu dem Trojaner, der da früher installiert wurde.
So, nun haben wir also den Salat, das heißt also, die Ermittlungsbehörden sagen, wir müssen, weil irgendwie die bösen Terroristen und die bösen Schwerkrinnen, die benutzen jetzt auch alle Computer und wir müssen da mithalten. Und wenn man sie gewährleist, führt es halt im Zweifel dazu, dass sie dann irgendwann nicht nur die Telefone, sondern auch nicht nur die Computer, sondern auch die Telefone und irgendwie den Videorekorder und was sonst noch so am Netz hängt, irgendwie zugreifen wollen. Und was wir eigentlich mit euch mal am Anfang diskutieren wollten, war die Frage, haltet ihr das denn eigentlich für gerechtfertigt? Also findet ihr so von einem so persönlichen Sicherheitsgefühl, dass es ein gerechtfertigter Eingriff ist? Entschuldigung, zur Erklärung, hier auf dem Fernseher läuft gerade die Reklame für Troja den Film. Anyway, also was wir von euch wissen wollen, ist, haltet ihr so einen Angriff mit einem Troja dafür gerechtfertigt, findet ihr, dass das BKA auf dem Computer von Verdächtigen rumschnüffeln können sollte, online oder findet ihr das nicht?
0331 70 97 1 ins 0 ist die Nummer der Fritz-Hottline und ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen, die Frage zu beantworten. Für wie gerechtfertigt haltet ihr das eigentlich?
Ja.
Ihr hört Chaosradio 122, hier auf Jazzradio Berlin, auf Fritz, also hier Fritz und auf Fritz, immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat das Chaosradio, heute ist es Ausgabe 122 und das Thema ist der Bundestrojaner und wir haben euch eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Die Frage zu beantworten, ob ihr es überhaupt für sinnfältig haltet, für gerechtfertig haltet, dass die Bundesregierung beziehungsweise wie nennt sich das berechtigte?
Behörden und Organisationen für Sicherheitsaufgaben? Das waren die anderen.
Man muss da schon grundsätzlich unterscheiden, wo die Forderung jetzt nach dem Bundestrojaner ist zunächst fürs BKA, also für unsere normalen polizeilichen Anbietungsbehörden. Für die Geheimdienste sieht ja die Rechtslage für den Bundestrojaner anders aus.
Da glauben sie zumindest, dass sie schon dürfen.
Ja genau, ergibt sich ja auch aus der Antwort von einer aktuellen Bundestagsanfrage. Außerdem gibt es noch Nordrhein-Westfalen, die haben ja eigens ein Gesetz geschaffen, um ihren Geheimdienst in die Lage zu versammeln.
Nordrhein-Westfalen hat einen eigenen Geheimdienst?
Ja, wenn man mal zusammenrechnet, so haben wir 16 Geheimdienste plus BND plus militärischer Abschirmdienst.
Ich dachte, es gäbe irgendwie dann das Landesnachrichtendienst Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Vielleicht gibt es ihn auch noch, wir wissen noch nicht davon.
Genau, als Tarnorganisation 0331 77 97 110.
Name?
Michael.
Unter welchen Umständen würdest du denn so einen Bundestrojaner zulassen?
Überhaupt nicht.
Warum denn nicht?
Und die Terroristen?
Welche Terroristen? Also ich sehe hier keine Terroristen.
Die sind ja auch im Internet, die verstecken sich da.
Ja, sicherlich. Mal die Festplatte hochheben. Vielleicht liegen sie da drunter.
Und was ist mit den ganzen Kinder-Pornografie-Händlern?
Ach ja, beliebte Totschlagargumente.
Also du siehst irgendwie da auch keine Rechtfertigung. Warum eigentlich?
Absolut nicht. Hat nix mit Demokratie zu tun, ganz einfach. Der Staat hat den Bürgern für die nicht umgekehrt. Und der Staat sind immer noch die Bürgern. Wenn der Staat oder die Politik seinen eigenen Bürgern nicht mehr vertraut, dann ist das halt ein Problem der Politik, aber nicht des Bürgers.
Naja, aber die Bürger wählen ja die Politiker. Also es ist ja 70% der Leute.
Also die hab ich nicht für mich.
Aber die Mehrheit, das ist eben Demokratie. Keiner kriegt weiter Wille und alle sind schuld. Also 70% dieser Bevölkerung wollen doch, dass diese Regierung uns so regiert, wie sie uns regiert, sagt die Regierung.
Ja, sagt die Regierung. Wenn ich eine entsprechende Umfrage in Auftrag gebe, dann wird die auch so ausfallen.
Das ist ja das Wahlergebnis.
Die Kernfrage ist ja am Ende...
Ja, dann sollte man jetzt mal eine Umfrage machen, ob die Bevölkerung im Moment auch so toll zufrieden ist mit der Regierung. Ob sie schon einbeisamieren lassen hat von diesen super Aufschwungen, die wir angeblich haben und alles super halala und toll und Arbeitsplätze entstehen angeblich, bist du nicht wo?
Na, wahrscheinlich beim BKA. Die interessante Frage ist ja, die Polizei hat ja auch unter normalen Umständen schon relativ weitgehende Befugnisse halt des Lebensbürgers einzugreifen, wenn sie das halt für nötig hält, um die Sicherheit irgendwie der größten Mehrzahl der Bürger zu schützen. Also zum Beispiel kann sie eine normale Hausdurchsuchung durchführen. Was wäre denn für dich?
Das wäre dann ein Zumin-E-Emin mit richterlichem Beschluss. Das ist ja ohne irgendwelchen Beschluss.
Ne, ne, bei Bundestrojaner...
Obwohl im Hintertürchen, hinter irgendwelchen geschlossenen Türen so heim ausgekungelt, sagen auch, da werden wir jetzt mal ein bisschen versuchen einzudringen.
Also beim Bundestrojaner sagen sie zumindest, auch wollen sie einen richterlichen Beschluss einführen. Also dass sie sozusagen für eine heimliche Online-Durchsuchung halten. Richterlichen Beschluss oder zumindest...
Aber bei der regulären Hausdurchsuchung müssen sie den dir vor die Nase halten. Dann kannst du den dir erstmal durchlesen und dann können sie deine Bude durchforsten. Aber da ist ein Richter, den du nicht kennst, von dem du nichts hörst, sagt, ja, könnte er machen, hat im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich keine Ahnung von der Materie und um sich nicht viel Arbeit zu machen, sagt er eben ja. Auch nicht, um sich eventuell Probleme von irgendeiner höheren Stelle...
Also für dich ist sozusagen dieser Heimlichkeitsaspekt ein wesentlicher Grund, das abzulehnen.
Aber da gibt es ja nun auch andere Ermittlungsnoten, gibt es ja zum Beispiel, wenn du an verdeckte Ermittler denkst, die werden dir ja auch nicht bekannt, wenn Personen dich ausspionieren.
Tja, das ist sicherlich ebenfalls ein Problem, aber... Da muss man ja nun wieder an anderer Stelle ansetzen. Und sicherlich gibt es einen anderen Grund, die verdeckten Ermittler können sicherlich hier oder da nützliche Vorarbeit leisten. Aber endlich muss ich ja den Staat doch irgendwann zu erkennen geben. Das tut er aber nicht, wenn er im Geheimhof den Rechner versucht einzudringen.
Für mich persönlich gibt es zwei wirklich drastische Aspekte. Das eine ist die Heimlichkeit, dass sie Stasi-Methoden verwenden.
Wollen, sodass man nicht mitbekommt, dass die Daten abhanden gekommen sind.
Man müsste nur mal weiter denken, wenn es die Stasi noch gäbe, die die gleichen technischen Möglichkeiten hätte, wie wir heute haben, würde die Stasi sich wahrscheinlich auch dieser Möglichkeiten bedienen.
Wir könnten sich auch in eine andere Richtung überlegen, wenn die DDR weiter existiert hätte, aber eben auf einem reformierten Kurs. Schließlich gab es da immerhin den malen Regierungswechsel und dieses neue Forum und Runde Tisch und so weiter.
Hat aber nicht funktioniert, wollte keiner haben. Ist doch Quatsch, darüber zu diskutieren, oder?
Das ist schon wieder ein ganz anderes Thema. Das ist so über Einfluss von außen hergekommen.
Nee, Michael, das ist jetzt schon wieder ein anderes Thema. Danke für deinen Anruf. Oder ein andermal. Ähm, ich glaube wir haben nur Ablehnung. Hallo Frank. Was machst du? Da bastelst du gerade den Bundestrojaner zusammen?
Ich befülle gerade eine Tankstelle.
Entschuldigung, was?
Du befüllst gerade eine Tankstelle.
Was man so macht.
Und was machst du so abends? Ja, ich befülle Tankstellen. Entschuldigung, du befüllst die mit Benzin?
Mit Benzin und Niveau, genau.
Wahnsinn.
Ja, die hat ja getankt, und da muss ja irgendwann mal was nachgefüllt werden, damit die Leute tanken können.
Mobiltelefonieren ist ja auch nur beim Tanken direkt selber verboten.
Das ist glaube ich auch der größte Schwachsinn, oder?
Das ist ja das Ungekehrte.
Ja, das könnte runterfallen, das Mobiltelefon, das könnte einen Funken schlagen, das ist der Hintergrund der Sache.
Das könnte runterfallen und einen Funken schlagen, verstehe ich.
Was denkst du da zu diesem Bundestrojaner?
Ja, also ich bin auch absolut dagegen, weil ich sag mal, da verlassen wir langsam den Bund mit Rechtsstatus. Weil wenn der Stadtbund mir was wissen will, dann möchte ich das schon die Anzehner wissen, wenn sie bei mir was ausspielen oder auskundschaften wollen. Und wie du vorhin gesagt hast, mit verdeckte Ermittler. Das ist ja so, die NPD konnte nicht verboten werden, weil dann verdeckte Ermittler eingesetzt wurden. Also dürfte das ja dann auch recht unkräftig sein, sag ich mal. Mit verdeckten ermittelten Daten.
Aber wäre ja nicht so, dass sie den Boden des Rechtsstatus verlassen wollen, weil sie wollen sich ja natürlich eine gesetzliche Grundlage schaffen, wenn sie können.
Naja, sicher. So ist die Kaltedition. Also für überdenklich, sag ich mal, ob Sonnigesetzungen von einem Bundesverfahrengericht bestehen würden, hab ich doch arge Zweifel.
Na, die haben wir natürlich auch. Also, du kannst dir tatsächlich überhaupt keine Umstände vorstellen und die ganzen Buzzwords wie Terrorismus oder Kinderporn, die sind für dich nicht interessant.
Naja, aber das ist nicht interessant, sagen wir mal so. Kinderporn ist sicher, das ist natürlich, da kann man auch andere Möglichkeiten, um das rauszukriegen. Dann ist das nicht oft genug angeboten eigentlich. Und mit dem Terrorismus, das ist so eine Sache. Ich meine, es kommen mehr Leute durch Verkehrsinfälle in Deutschland um, als durch Terrorismus. Autofahren war auch nicht verboten. Also, das wird noch viel benützt, dieses Argument, sag ich mal so.
Okay, also du siehst da nicht wirklich Handlungsbedarf, ganz im Gegensatz zu unserem BKA-Chef, der ganz dringend diesen Bundestrojaner möchte.
Mit dem habt ihr die Woche auch noch irgendwie konferiert, oder? Frank, besten Dank! Nichts zu danken! Und viel Spaß beim Befüllen noch!
Und schöne Handyfestheiten nicht aufhören lassen!
Ich wollte übrigens jetzt jonglieren lernen, und dann stelle ich mich immer auf den Tank und jongliere mit Feuersteinen. Mal gucken, was dann passiert. Name Roland!
Ja, Name, also ich finde das Ding auch nicht gut. Es ist einfach nur Stasi-Methode und Totalüberwachung passt zur Kontenabfrage und Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu allem.
Was ich nicht verstehe, ehrlich gesagt, ist, es gibt 17 Millionen Leute in diesem Land, die sich an die Stasi noch aktiv erinnern können. Und eigentlich müsste doch ein Aufschrei durch mindestens diesen Teil der Bevölkerung gehen, wenn die hören, dass jetzt die konspirative Durchsuchung der Wohnung wieder eingeführt wird in einem demokratischen Rechtsstaat.
Ich denke, dass ja, das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen den meisten überhaupt nicht bewusst ist, in welcher starke Eingriffstiefe dieses Software Tool hat. Also vielen ist ja gar nicht klar, was man mit so einem Trojaner machen kann. Und es gibt natürlich auch einen großen Teil der Bevölkerung, der nicht betroffen ist, weil er mit irgendwie Computern nicht viel am Hut hat.
Ich glaube, er hat nichts zu verbergen.
Na gut, das hatten die Leute, die in deren Wohnungen eingebrochen wurden, in der DDR auch, und das ist natürlich im Zweifelsfall.
Lass doch mal bitte Roland erzählen. Ich wollte dich mal fragen, Roland.
Ja, ich denke auch mal, die meisten Leute sind einfach desinteressiert.
Denen geht das am Arsch vorbei einfach. Die sagen auch, ich hab nichts zu verbergen. Ich wollte eigentlich noch eine Frage mit anhängen, und zwar dieser Bundestrojaner, wird denn der irgendwie betriebssystemabhängig sein oder ist das universeller Java-Code, was jedes Betriebssystem ausführen kann, oder ist das irgendwie so eine niedrige Netzwerkprotokollschicht, die dann einfach sagt, frage jeden Sektor da Festplatte ab, oder?
Entschuldigung, ich stell mir gerade vor, wie das auf jeder Plattform ausführbarer Java-Code ist, und hier beim RBB praktisch auf jedem Rechner als erstes eine Fehlermeldung aufspringt und sagt, Sie haben hier keine JRE installiert.
Wie soll denn das Ding funktionieren?
Ja, also einen plattformübergreifenden Trojaner wird es da so einfach mal definitiv nicht geben. Das ist ganz klar. Also es gibt so viele verschiedene Betriebssysteme, sehr viele freie Betriebssysteme, die müssen da schon individuell angepasst und entwickelt werden. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man einen hat und alle damit kompromittieren könnte.
Es ist ja auch so, wenn es den ultimativen Trojaner geben würde, dann würde schon einfach mal eingesetzt werden. Den gibt es natürlich nicht.
Also was so dem zu entnehmen ist, was in der Presse zu lesen ist und aus den Aussagen von Ländern, wo solche Systeme schon mal eingesetzt werden, ist es so, dass da eher so eine Art Toolkit entwickelt wird, was benutzt werden kann, verschiedene Angriffswege benutzen kann, die wiederum auf die verschiedenen Betriebssysteme abgestimmt sind und die dann auch jeweils aktuell gehalten werden müssen. Das heißt also, der Staat dann halt einfach auch relativ viel Geld und Wissen aufwenden muss, um so ein Angriffswerkzeug halt auf dem Stand der Technik zu halten und gegen die normal eingeführten Schutzmittel bzw. die Schutzmittel, die halt auf dem Rechner des Verdächtigen angewendet werden, halt irgendwie zu wappnen. Und da gibt es halt dutzende verschiedene Angriffsmethoden. Also es wird halt nicht den Bundestrojaner geben, auch wenn der Begriff halt so schön plakativ benutzbar ist.
Wäre das theoretisch möglich, den, sagen wir mal, heimlich auf die Startseite von Google einzubauen, sodass sich den automatisch jeder runterlädt?
Du kannst alles Mögliche irgendwo auf eine Webseite packen. Das Problem ist da in dem Moment der User, wenn er sich das ganze Ding runterlädt und installiert.
Sodass da eben halt keine Meldungen aufpoppt. Die werden alle abgeblockt.
Ich meine, wenn du einen Webbrowser benutzt, der irgendwelche Schwachstellen hat, dann kann man so etwas eventuell hinkriegen, dass das eben kleinzeitig ausgenutzt wird, diese Schwachstelle und sich dann irgendeine Software installiert. Das passiert doch häufig. Ich meine, das ist halt gerade so Werbezeug. Das sind ja letztlich auch irgendwie eine Art von Trojaner, die dann noch weitere Features zu deinem Browser hinzufügen, die du eigentlich gar nicht willst. Aber grundsätzlich ist es nicht möglich. Wie gesagt, kann man eventuell ausnutzen, wenn es kleinzeitige Schwachstellen gibt.
Danke Roland.
Gute Nacht, Tschüss.
Wir machen Nachrichten.
Auf Sweet Escape Tour am 14.
September im Velodrom Berlin.
Und das hört man um 2, 5.11.
Mit Grisha Sidelke. Das iranische Staatsfernsehen hat Aufnahmen einer britischen Soldatin und ihrer ebenfalls festgehaltenen Kameraden ausgestrahlt. Die britische Regierung bezeichnete die Ausstrahlung der Aufnahmen in einer ersten Reaktion als inakzeptabel. Premierminister Blair sagte, die iranische Führung müsse begreifen, dass sie sich in völliger Isolation befinde. Satellitenbilder belegen nach Ansichten des britischen Verteidigungsministeriums, dass die Marineangehörigen nicht in iranische Gewässer eingedrungen sind. US-Präsident Bush hat dem russischen Präsidenten Putin Gespräche über den umstrittenen Raketenschutzschild angeboten. Er sei bereit, Russlands über Details des Abwehrsystems zu informieren. Das teilte die russische Regierung mit. Putin habe seinerseits dem US-Präsidenten die Bedenken Russlands gegen die geplante Stationierung von US-Raketen in Polen dargelegt. Die tschechische Regierung hat inzwischen die Aufnahme offizieller Verhandlungen mit den USA über den Aufbau des umstrittenen Raketenabwehrsystems angekündigt. Die Spitzengespräche der großen Koalitions- und Thema Mindestlöhne sind beendet. Nach der Runde im Kanzleramt gab es keine Erklärung, da Vertraulichkeit vereinbart worden war. Damit blieb offen, ob sich Union und SPD in den koalitionsinternen Dauerkonflikt angenähert haben. Die SPD will gesetzliche Mindestlöhne für weitere Branchen durchsetzen und über das Entsendegesetz regeln. Die Union lehnt verbindliche Mindestlöhne entschieden ab. Für Sport, Fußball, die deutsche Nationalmannschaft hat ihr Test für Länderspiel gegen Dänemark mit 0 zu 1 verloren und Basketball. Cup-Verteidiger Albert Berlin ist im Viertelfinale des deutschen Basketball-Pokals ausgeschieden. Albert unterlag 69 zu 74 bei Rhein Energie Köln. In der Nacht gibt es ein paar Wolken, regnen soll es aber nicht. Die Temperaturen gehen runter auf 6 bis 1 Grad, am Tag wird es wieder sonnig, allerdings kommen mehr Wolken dazu und vereinzelt kann es auch mal regnen. Das Ganze bei maximal 17 Grad. Der Verkehr auf Fritz A2 Magdeburg Richtung Berliner Ring zwischen Herziäser und Wollin ist der rechte Fahrstreifen blockiert, dort brennt derzeit ein Auto. Ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine gute Fahrt.
Danke Grisha, 411.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6 dann Fritz in Berlin.
Was war das denn?
Das war wohl der nächste Song in der Playlist.
Du musst das ins Mikrofon sagen, damit jeder weiß, dass du es warst. Komm mal, Bürschchen.
Ich war es nicht.
Was ist jetzt los? Herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 122. Was war das, was wir gerade gehört haben?
Das war aus der Playlist ein Podcast.
Wollen wir mal tanzen gehen?
Ich bin als DJ nicht so geübt.
Du meinst Haare schütteln, Heugin?
Heatbenchen, wie wir Rocker sagen. Also wenn ich mir das angucke, was bei Frank da oben aus dem T-Shirt kommt. Chaosradio 122. Es geht um den Bundestrojaner und die Frage nach wie vor, findet ihr das gut oder findet ihr das schlecht? Und falls ihr es gut findet, unter welchen Umständen findet ihr es denn gut? Und wir haben tatsächlich jemanden, der es gut findet. Christopher.
Also ich bin eigentlich sonst durchaus ein bisschen anarchistisch veranlagt.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also du bist genau der Christopher, von dem ich jetzt nicht erwartet hätte, dass er sagt, er findet den Bundestrojaner gut.
Genau, aber lass mich mal...
Du bist ein Troll.
Nee, und zwar, ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, dass es hier um die Bekämpfung von Gewaltkriminalität oder organisierten Verbrechen geht. Und das heißt, das sind für mich Dinge, ich finde man muss sich wirklich mal überlegen, was jeder Fall von Gewalt bedeutet für einen einzelnen Menschen, für das Schicksal, für die Psyche von einem Menschen. Ich denke, jedes einzelne Gewaltverbrechen ist ein tiefer Einschnitt ins Leben. Zum Glück bin ich davon noch nicht betroffen, aber wenn ich mir das vorstelle, dann wege ich einfach ab. Dann würde ich mir sagen, wenn man einfach Menschen dadurch retten kann, selbst wenn man vielleicht tausend oder paar tausend Computer durchforstet und dadurch die Psyche eines Menschen retten kann vor traumatischen Erfahrungen, dann würde ich sagen, dann wäre ich sozusagen bereit, dass man meinen Computer dafür durchforstet.
Ist ja interessant. Ich finde den Ansatz natürlich ein bisschen totalitaristisch.
Ja, aber ich finde die Voraussetzung ist natürlich, dass wir unserer Demokratie noch einigermaßen vertrauen.
Okay, also nehmen wir mal ein konkretes Beispiel aus der Vergangenheit. Die Mautdaten. Das Mautdatengesetz wurde so verfasst, dass es explizit keinen Zugriff der Strafverfolgungsbehörden auf die Mautdaten geben sollte. Da hat sogar irgendwie damals der Innenminister, das war glaube ich noch Mr. Schilley, rumgetönt. Also wir haben ja da alle Bedenken im Griff und so weiter und so fort. Ja und nun wurde einfach dieses Gesetz dahingehend geändert, dass es halt einfach im Wesentlichen für alle Zwecke der Strafverfolgung ein Problem ist möglich ist, auf diese Daten zuzugreifen.
Ja, aber ich...
Anderes Beispiel noch mal, zum Beispiel die Telefonüberwachung. Wie gerade irgendwie der Herr Dix, der Berliner Datenschutzbeauftragte in seinem jüngsten Bericht publiziert hat, wurde die Telefonüberwachung von der Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft eingesetzt, um hinter jemanden herzusteigen, der auf eBay gebraucht Möbel vertickt hat. Und auch die Telefonüberwachung wurde uns präsentiert. Also wir werden es nur anwenden, wenn es wirklich ganz schlimmes Menschenhandel mit Kinder, Porno und irgendwie Terrorismus verbunden ist. Und die Tendenz ist halt einfach, dass sobald die Strafverfolgungsbehörden irgendein Werkzeug haben, werden sie es halt einfach routinemäßig benutzen.
Weißt du, ich sag mir einfach, solange ich mein privates, persönliches Leben frei leben kann und was weiß ich, einfach die Dinge, die man, die ein normaler Mensch irgendwie zur Gestaltung seines Lebens, an die Entscheidung, wie er trifft, solange der Staat sich das vollkommen raushält, ist mir das persönlich eigentlich vollkommen egal, was der Staat über mich ausforscht.
Das Problem ist nur, dass der Staat, wenn er auf deinen Rechner zugrafen kann, dann kannst du dich nicht mehr ganz normal entfalten. Bestandteil meines Lebens zum Beispiel ist es mit einigen, die in diesem Staat passieren, ziemlich deutlich nicht einverstanden zu sein, was dagegen zu tun. Im Rahmen der demokratischen Grundordnung, aber wie wir mittlerweile auch wissen, gibt es da auch einige Mitspieler in Deutschland auf Seiten der Behörden, die irgendwie nicht so gut finden. Moment, lass mich mal auswähnen. Und wenn jetzt der Staat in der Lage wäre, ohne größere Federlesens auf meiner Platte rumzustöbern, so wie er momentan ohne große Federlesens dazu in der Lage ist, mein Telefon abzuhören, um meine E-Mails zu überwachen, dann könnte ich mein Leben einfach nicht mehr frei entfalten. Also für mich persönlich wäre zum Beispiel ein Trojaner-Angriff wesentlich schlimmer als eine Wohnraumüberwachung, weil irgendwie in meinem Schlafzimmer hört er mich genau schnarchen und irgendwie mit meinen Kindern reden, aber irgendwie...
Kein Sex?
Wir haben mehrere Schlafzimmer.
Das ist doch im Prinzip so, als würde ich mich darüber kümmern, was die Oma von nebenan oder meinen Sohnstil sagt. Das ist mir im Prinzip egal.
Wenn sie mir auf der Festplatte rumstöbern, da ist irgendwie ein größerer Teil meines Lebens verankert und gespeichert. Und das betrachte ich als tatsächlich ein Eingriff, so wie es das Bundesverfassungsgericht definiert hat, in meine persönliche Lebensgestaltung. Wenn ich nicht mehr Dinge auf meinem Computer speicheln kann und nicht sicher sein kann, dass sie niemand anders sieht.
Naja, das gehört einfach zu meiner anarchistischen Lebenshaltung, dass ich versuche mir einfach zu sagen, es ist mir einfach scheißegal, dass die anderen über mich denken. Solange sie mich deswegen terrorisieren oder einsperren...
Aber genau das werden sie ja tun, Christoph.
Ja, aber das ist genau der Punkt, dass man sich sagt, vertrauen wir unserer Demokratie noch so weit, dass wir glauben, dass der Normalbürger seine Grundrechte behält oder haben wir daran schon Zweifel? Weil das wäre im Prinzip der Punkt, um den es eigentlich geht, dass wir sagen, es ist nicht das Problem des Datenschutzes, sondern wir trauen unserem Staat eigentlich so wenig, dass wir fürchten, dass es morgen eine Diktatur ist, die uns elementare Menschenrechte beraubt. Das wäre eigentlich der Punkt, um den es dann geht.
Das Problem ist glaube ich noch nicht mal so sehr, dass der Staat oder die Behörden uns diese Rechte berauben, sondern man beraubt sich diese Rechte selbst. Wenn du jetzt vorhast, eine Opposition zu gründen, eine wie auch immer geartete, und dich dazu mit zehn anderen Gleichgesinnten triffst und ihr fangt an zu diskutieren, dann kann es durchaus passieren, dass irgendjemand da in eurer Runde sitzt und sagt, eigentlich müsste man den Bundesinnenminister erschießen. So, alle verdrehen die Augen und das Thema ist gegessen, weil es einfach nur irgendeine wirre Äußerung im SUF oder sonst was ist. Wenn du jetzt aber davon ausgehen musst, dass du permanent abgehört wirst dabei, dann wirst du es zu so einem Zusammentreffen nicht mehr kommen lassen, weil du Angst haben musst, dass irgendwann mal Max Mütze im SUF sagt, er will den Bundesinnenminister erschießen. Weil dann hat nämlich derjenige, der euch abgehört hat, euch alle am Arsch. Sagt euch ein und sagt, das ist eine Planung eines terroristischen Anschlags.
Wenn der Staat so abartig ist und so viele Daten sammelt, dann hat er ja, das ist ja letztendlich, stellt er sich damit ja selbst eine Falle. Weil das war ja letztendlich auch, denke ich, am Ende auch ein Problem der Stasi. Wenn du so viel Daten erfasst, dickst du am Ende ja gar nicht mehr durch. Das heißt, diese Datenerfassung, die muss der Staat ja eigentlich von sich aus, der muss ja selektieren.
Also das Problem ist Folgendes. Ich hab das schon mal ein bisschen extremer geäußert und hab da viel, viel Dresche bekommen, aber ich glaube immer noch, dass ich dabei recht habe. Wo wir hinsteuern, ist eine Gesellschaft, die mit den multiplen Krisen, die vor uns zukommen, sei es Klimakatastrophe, sei es irgendwie Globalisierung und so weiter und so fort, einfach nicht mehr klarkommt, außer durch Repression. Und was wir gerade sehen momentan, ist, dass die Sicherheitsbehörden gezielt sich die Instrumente aufbauen, um, falls irgendwie mal irgendwie die braune Soße in den Ventilator fliegt, in der Lage zu sein, diese Gesellschaft noch unter Kontrolle zu halten. Und dazu gehört, dass Kritiker selektiv und willkürlich bestraft werden können. Und wovon da viele Leute träumen und sagen, die für ihre Konferenzen auch öffentlich ist, ein semi-automatisches Strafsystem, wo halt irgendwie niemand mehr draufgucken muss, wenn sie dich wegen irgendwie rot über die Ampel laufen, mit der Überwachungskammer gefilmt haben. Und das ist der Staat, auf den wir zusteuern. Er wird halt immer noch demokratisch sein. Es wird halt immer noch ein gewähltes Parlament geben. Nur wird es halt einfach so sein, dass dein Bewegungsspielraum halt immer enger wird. Und der Bewegungsspielraum von Leuten, die irgendwas an diesem System auszusetzen haben, immer noch viel, viel enger wird. Und dieser Bundestrojaner ist nach meiner Ansicht tatsächlich nur ein Puzzlestein in diesem ganzen Spiel. Also die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zum Beispiel ist noch so ein Puzzlestein. Also wenn die Vorratsdatenspeicherung durchgeht, dann leben wir in einem Überwachungsstaat. Dann müssen wir nicht mehr damit sagen, da wird es einen Überwachungsstaat geben, sondern dann ist einfach mal wer telefoniert mit wem und wer e-mailt mit wem die ganze Zeit für alle Bürger ohne jegliche Ausnahme in den Datenbanken.
Verdachtsunabhängig.
Und die werden dann auch benutzt werden.
Ja, aber also...
Im Montag ist es halt so, dass das einzige, was noch zwischen uns und irgendwie tatsächlich einem Überwachungsstaat steht, ist das Bundesverfassungsgericht und das ist nicht viel.
Also ich sehe halt diesen Ansatz nicht, dass der Staat im Moment schon so weit ist, dass er normale Bürger im Prinzip bespitzelt, nur weil die eine Meinung haben, die nicht sagen wir irgendwie massenkonform ist.
Erzählt das mal Greenpeace. Erzählt das mal Greenpeace. Also de facto ist es der Fall. Also ich meine, es ist sogar so, dass irgendwie die, wir hier verdeckte Ermittler von ausländischen Polizeibehörden in irgendwelchen Aktivistengruppen haben.
Du kannst dir zum Beispiel auch gerne mal den Leuten erzählen, die bei den Atomtransporten als Gegner dort irgendwo aufgegriffen werden oder mal mit deren Anwälten sprechen. Von Telefonüberwachung bis hin zu verdeckter Ermittlung alles mögliche. Weil sie einfach nur ein Grundrecht, was sie haben, nämlich das zu demonstrieren, benutzen.
Ich muss sagen, da bin ich vielleicht ein bisschen ignorant, aber selbst das würde mich nicht stören, solange ich der Staat deswegen nicht einsperrt oder was macht, was mich wirklich...
Hast du jemals in einem privaten Gespräch zu einem Freund gesagt, das ist etwas, was ich schon mal gesagt habe, wenn ich irgendwann die Diagnose kriege, nur noch ein paar Monate zu leben zu haben, dann werde ich mich bewaffnet und dann werde ich losziehen und einige Leute mitnehmen. Hast du sowas jemals gesagt?
Nee, das habe ich nicht gesagt. Nehmen wir mal an, ich hätte es gesagt. Also wenn der Staat alle diese Äußerungen aufzeichnen würde, dann hätte er doch selbst ein Problem, weil er im Prinzip mit dieser Informationsmasse, die könnte er ja gar nicht mehr auswerten, weil er nicht mehr unterscheiden könnte, ob Hans Müller das gestern mit Ironie aus Spaß gesagt hat oder ob er es ernst macht.
Deswegen wird er halt einfach alle bestrafen. Das ist der einfache Weg.
Aber dieser Ansatz ist doch nicht erkennbar.
Ich meine, in Deutschland sind wir gerade so daran vorbeigeschrammt, dass irgendwie Leute verurteilt wurden dafür, dass sie durchgeschrichene Hakenkreuze auf Armen getragen haben.
Sie haben eigentlich sogar noch krassere Beispiele. Denkt doch mal an Murat Konas und an El Masri. Das sind die klassischen Beispiele von Menschen, die nichts getan haben, aber die hatten ein paar schlechte Einträge in Datenbanken.
Moment mal, ich muss sagen, vielleicht bin ich da doch ein bisschen naiv, aber was über Murat Konas, die Lebensgeschichte und in was für Kreisen er sich auffällt, das ist ja nun mal nicht das eigentlich, was ich...
Du meinst, Leute sollten bestraft werden, weil sie die falschen Freunde haben.
Es ist einfach so, es gibt Menschen, die haben eine fragwürdige Lebensgeschichte und halten sich im Kreis auf die...
Inklusive Drogen, inklusive Diebstahl und Körperverletzung.
Dafür muss ich ein Mist.
Nein, es ist aber einfach so, jemand, der sich in solchen Kreisen aufhält. Für den ist einfach das Risiko größer. Der gehört doch im weitesten Sinne zu dieser...
Er soll in den Knast, weil er die falschen Freunde hat.
Nein, nicht in den Knast.
Nein, das ist das, was du sagst.
Nee, wenn ich mich aber einfach mit... Nehme mal an, ich hätte schlechte Freunde...
Pass auf, ich kann dir ganz einfach machen. Du nimmst mir deine Telefonnummer und ich ruf dich von ein paar Telefonleitungen an, von denen du echt nicht angerufen werden solltest. So, das geht ganz schnell. Dann schicke ich dir noch ein paar E-Mails und lege noch ein paar Spuren, die so aussehen, als wärst du auf den falschen Webseiten gewesen.
Genau, dann würde ich sagen, ich fände es angemessen, wenn jemand überprüfen würde, ob ich einfach ein Kandidat bin.
Das ist bei Robert Kurnas zum Beispiel aber gar nicht überprüft worden, sondern den haben sie direkt weggesperrt. Da hat niemand überhaupt nur irgendwas überprüft. Da haben sogar die Amis noch überprüft und sind zum Schluss gekommen, der Typ ist ungefährlich. Und die Deutschen haben gesagt, den wollen wir nicht haben. Türke brauchen wir nicht.
Nachdem was ich so gelesen habe, kann man ja glaube ich nicht einwandfrei sagen, dass Moral Kurnas im Prinzip...
Im Zweifel für den Angeklagten, Christopher. Das ist ein wesentlicher Grundsatz, wenn nicht sogar der Grundsatz des Rechtsstaates.
Es geht ja nicht um eine Verurteilung.
Entschuldige, jetzt werde ich aber echt sauer. Wie lange darf denn jemand im Knast verrotten, bis es nicht einer Verurteilung oder einer Bestrafung gleichkommt? Nein, der Typ ist für Jahre weggesperrt worden. Ohne irgendetwas, ohne dass irgendjemand geprüft oder verurteilt hat. Einfach nur, weil irgendwelche Geheimdienste oder was weiß ich was für Dienste...
Das lehne ich auch ab.
Ja, aber es passiert. Es passiert und die Politiker, die eigentlich dafür verantwortlich wären zu sagen, Moment mal, hier ist Scheiße passiert, die sagen, das war doch alles völlig normal. Das war ja nur ein Türke.
Nee, es ist nicht nur ein Türke, aber ich denke, er hat sich einfach in fragwürdigen Kreisen aufgehalten.
Du kannst dir wahrscheinlich auch einfach nicht vorstellen, dass es genau dich treffen könnte, wie es ihn getroffen hat.
Ich denke mal, jeder normale Bürger, der sich irgendwie in einigermaßen normalen Kreisen aufhält...
Was ist denn für dich normal?
Also jedenfalls nicht einer, der sich unter Fundamentalisten aufhält.
Ja, ich meine, es kann sein, dass er Journalisten trifft, zum Beispiel, die sich unter Fundamentalisten aufhalten müssen, weil es ihr Job ist, da zu recherchieren, das ist auch schon vorgekommen. Die hatten dann plötzlich irgendwie vier Monate Telefonüberwachung am Hals und bekamen ihre E-Mails vorgelesen. Also der Grundsatz der Unschuldsvermutung, der halt damit halt irgendwie, also mit der Vorurtsdauer entsprechend zum Beispiel ausgehebelt wird, ist halt irgendwie bei dieser Trojaner-Geschichte... Also das ist noch viel krasser aus technischen Gründen. Wenn die versuchen meinen Rechner anzugreifen, so in meinem Netzwerk sind noch vier, fünf andere Rechner. So und nicht nur meine. So und wenn sie das in einer Firma machen, da sind noch 20 andere Rechner. Nicht nur meine. Und die werden dann halt bei der Gelegenheit auch mit angegriffen.
Ja, ich finde, ihr macht euch jedenfalls ein bisschen einfacher. Ich sehe halt schon, dass der Staat einfach auch einen sehr schweren Job hat in der Hinweise.
Es ist doch nicht so, dass irgendwie der BKA eine zahnlose Minke wäre und keine Methoden hätte. Also es ist ja so, dass die Ermittlungsbehörden hier in Deutschland alle Möglichkeiten haben. Sie haben personell die Möglichkeiten, sie haben sie auch technisch.
Ja, aber die organisierte Kriminalität, die rüstet ja auch auf. Und ich denke mir immer, wenn die organisierte Kriminalität eure Reden hören, die lachen sich einfach tot, die bedanken sich einfach bei euch.
Na ja, aber bloß, klar ist doch, dass Prinzip Menschen, die wollen, sich gegen so einen Bundestrojaner effektiv schützen können. Wer sich technisch aufrüstet, der wird nicht betroffen sein von diesem Bundestrojaner. Insofern ist organisierte Kriminalität natürlich kein Argument. Weil wer sich ernsthaft mit den Techniken auseinandersetzt, der wird sich schützen können. Insofern greift ja dieses ganze Konzept des Trojaners auf uns Leere.
Es geht ja bei allen Maßnahmen der Polizei letztlich darum, einfach den Verbrechern ihren Job einfach schwerer zu machen.
Ja, das ist aber nicht so, dass die Polizei noch keine Befugnisse hätte, im Gegenteil. Was wir halt sehen, ist, dass bei jeder einzelnen Maßnahme winken sie immer mit den Terroristen und den Schwerkriminellen und natürlich den Kinderpornografen. Und am Ende wird die Maßnahme soweit aufgebläht, dass sie gegen ungefähr alle eingesetzt wird und nicht mehr gegen die Leute, für die sie angeblich gedacht war, weil die benutzen die Technologien schon lange nicht mehr, die damit verbunden sind.
Wir sind ja auch nicht ein Land, wo Frau Kriminellen nur so wimmelt. Wir haben eine seit vielen Jahren rückläufige Kriminalstatistik. Die gefühlte Kriminalität ist eine ganz andere Frage.
Ich weiß, dass da durchaus ein Unterschied ist. Aber ich muss sagen, ich gehöre halt zu den Glücklichen, die eben von Kriminalität noch nicht betroffen sind. Und insofern müsste ich es eigentlich lockerer sehen. Aber ich bin glaube ich einfach total froh, dass ich eben noch kein Opfer geworden bin. Ich glaube, wenn ich das wäre, dann Menschen, die einfach wirklich diesen Schaden erlitten haben, ich glaube, dass sie das anders beurteilen. Weil wir sitzen hier so gemütlich rum und philosophieren so ein bisschen und sagen, der Staat soll uns nicht mit diesen ganzen Überwachungsterroren nerven und wir wollen nicht wieder so werden wie die DDR. Rundpunkt. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich hab das Gefühl, dass es eben nicht so einfach ist. Also mir persönlich, mir tut es halt einfach nicht weh. Also es sind halt andere, gut, die haben vielleicht eine andere Wahrnehmung, die fühlt sich in ihrer freien Entfaltung der Persönlichkeit eingeschränkt. Ich weiß nicht, ich versuch einfach zu ignorieren, wenn andere mich einschränken wollen. Solange die mich nicht einsperren und mir direkt das Leben schwer machen, sag ich, Leute, ihr könnt mich mal, ich lebe mein Leben.
Vermutlich bist du auch nicht unbedingt in der Minderheit hier in der Bundesrepublik. Also mir scheint schon, dass es eine ganze Menge Leute gibt, die so denken wie du.
Ich wüsste ganz gerne, Christophe, woher du denn jetzt weißt, dass sie dich nicht morgen einsperren werden. Woher weißt du das?
Ich glaube, das ist von der Wahrscheinlichkeit statistisch gering. Und wenn es passieren würde, passiert halt, was weiß ich, natürlich passiert wahrscheinlich von 500.000 Menschen oder von so unzuvieh tausend Menschen, passiert halt ein, dass er irgendwo mal in ein Knast landet in Deutschland und unterwugungshaft und verdächtigt wird. Aber ich glaube einfach, je mehr man im Prinzip ein, sagen wir mal, ein sich selbst treues Leben führt, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit einfach weiter sinkt. Das heißt, ich bin natürlich nicht 100% sicher verschont, aber ich denke, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es nicht trifft, ist statistisch halt relativ gering. Und dieses Restrisiko, ja, was soll man machen? Das muss man wahrscheinlich einfach in Kauf nehmen. In anderen Ländern...
Glaubst du nicht, dass sich dein Verhalten ändert, wenn du weißt, dass du sonst ein Risiko läufst?
Aber guck mal, das Leben ist doch voller Risiken.
Ich meine, die spezifische Frage ist folgende. Also wissenschaftlich belegt sind die Auswirkungen von Überwachung, dass die Leute ihr Verhalten an die von den Überwachern gewünschten Muster anpassen. Also zum Beispiel bei Kamerüberwachung ist das durchaus belegt. Und auch bei anderen Formen von Überwachung ist das so, dass die Leute halt anfangen, bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr zu tun, weil sie irgendwie implizit annehmen, dass sie überwacht werden.
Ich kann mir doch einfach überlegen, will ich diese Unfreiheit der Überwachung in Kauf nehmen, oder will ich dieses Risiko, oder will ich das Risiko in Kauf nehmen, dass ich Opfer von Kriminalität bin?
Dieses Risiko, Christopher, war doch aber vorgestern nicht höher als es heute ist. Warum muss ich dann heute schwerere Geschütze auffahren?
Aber das eine Risiko tut mir nicht weh, während mir das andere sehr weh tut. Also einfach von meiner Empfindung. Mir tut es halt nicht weh, wenn ich über die Straße laufe und ich sehe deine Kamera. Es tut mir aber weh, auch wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht so groß ist. Aber es tut mir verdammt weh, wenn ich Opfer von einem Überfall werde.
Mir fällt ja das Beispiel mit dem Frosch ein, den man in ein Wasserglas setzt. Und dann erhöht man die Temperatur langsam. Und der Frosch wird es nicht merken, bis er tot ist.
Also ich denke, absolute Freiheit gibt es einfach nicht. Also wenn ich einfach diese zwei Risiken wählen kann...
Aber es gibt doch keine absolute Sicherheit.
Um auf dein Kriminalitätsargument zurückzukommen, wenn diese Maßnahmen tatsächlich dazu dienen würden, die Kriminalität zu senken, dann müsste die Bundesregierung bzw. das Bundesministerium ja auch keinerlei Scheu davor haben, das zu belegen und zu sagen, passt auf, guck mal, irgendwie mit der Telefonüberwachung haben wir letztes Jahr irgendwie diese und diese schweren Jungs gefangen. Und irgendwie mit den und den Überwachungsmaßnahmen haben wir letztes Jahr diese und jene Kriminalität verhindert und diese und jene Übeltäter von der Straße geholt. Doch, in den USA gibt es da eine wunderschöne Statistik, die kann man sogar klicken. Das FBI macht das sogar bis auf einzelne Fälle runter. Die haben offensichtlich gar kein Problem damit. Die können sagen, pass auf, in diesem Prozess haben wir mit den Beweisen aus der Telefonüberwachung den Prozess gewonnen, der Junge ist jetzt 15 Jahre im Knast. So kann man danach klicken. In Deutschland hat die Bundesinnenministerkonferenz gesagt, und zwar mehrfach hintereinander, dass sie eine Auswertung dieser Art nicht wünscht, weil sonst die politische Unterstützung für die weitere Durchführung der Telefonüberwachung schwinden könnte.
Das Problem ist im Prinzip, das der Bevölkerung Schmackkasten zu machen, ihr zu verkaufen.
Ich glaube, es ging gerade nicht um die Befehlungen.
Es ging einfach darum, dass sie einfach sich weigern, zu belegen, dass diese Maßnahmen irgendeine Art von kriminalitätsreduzierendem Erfolg haben. Weil wenn sie es nicht tun, müssten wir sogar deiner Logik nach, wenn sie sagen können, okay, wir führen diese Maßnahmen ein, wir probieren sie 5 Jahre aus. Wir sehen, die Kriminalität, zumindest im Schwerstkriminalitätsbereich, wird dadurch nicht reduziert und wir haben dadurch nur sehr geringe Ermittlungserfolge. Aber wir schränken damit die Freiheit des Bürgers substanziell ein, müssten wir diese Maßnahmen theoretisch rückgängig machen. Das tun sie aber nicht und zwar systematisch nicht, was eigentlich darauf hinweist, dass sie es nicht ehrlich spielen.
Das heißt, man muss gar nicht sagen, müssten, also eigentlich hat der Gesetzgeber eine Pflicht.
Stimmt, sie ignorieren es.
Also sie müssen nicht nur sagen, dass ihre Gesetze formell korrekt sind, sondern sie müssen auch sagen, ob sie inhaltlich den Zweck erfüllen, der mit dem Gesetz gemeint war.
Vor welches Gericht kann ich denn dann die Innenministerkonferenz zerren?
Also worauf ich hinaus will, ist einfach der Punkt. Lass dich nicht von dieser Argumentation, das hilft aber gegen die bösen Kriminellen, Blenden. Was gegen böse Kriminelle hilft, ist mehr Polizeibeamte einstellen, die tatsächlich Ermittlungsarbeit machen. Und wenn ich mir angucke, wie die heutzutage da sitzen, in ihren Wachen und da teilweise immer noch irgendwie Windows 95-PCs haben und nicht mal funktionierende Software haben, wenn in einigen Bundesländern die Polizei nicht mehr zum Einsatz ausrücken kann, weil sie kein Benzin mehr in den Autos hat. Ja, in Brandenburg ist das passiert. Dann frage ich mich, warum wird Geld für so einen Quatsch ausgegeben, der tatsächlich die Kriminalität kein Stück reduziert?
Aber ich meine, öffentliche Firmen, die ja wirklich nur nach Kosten und Nutzen denken, warum gibt es bei Firmen so viele Kameras? Also ich meine, die wissen doch eigentlich, was sich rechnet.
Damit sie hinterher gucken können, welcher ihrer Mitarbeiter sie beklaut hat.
Das ist auch Versicherungstechnik.
Also an der Tanke, an der ich gearbeitet habe, da gab es Kameras, und die gab es da nicht um irgendwie Kriminalität oder sonst was, sondern der Chef hat gesagt, glaub nicht, das ist wegen Überfällen, das ist, damit ich sehe, wenn du Zigaretten klaust. Hat der klipp und klar gesagt. Und wenn ich sehe, dass du sitzt, während ein Kunde im Laden ist, schmeiße ich dich raus. Dafür wollen die Kameras. Klare Ansage. Ja, habe ich auch nicht lange gearbeitet. Christopher, vielen Dank für diesen Mut. Gute Nacht. Tschüss. Chaosradio 122, der Bundestrojaner. Chaosradio 122, das Thema ist der Bundestrojaner. Wir haben noch jede Menge Leute in der Leitung, die auch was zu sagen wollen. Fangen wir an mit Yves? Das ist komplett komisch geschrieben, wie dein Name hier auf dem Bildschirm steht. Entschuldige. Hallo Yves. Hallo. Ich frage das jetzt jedem, den wir noch reinstellen in die Sendung. Du hast eben Christopher gehört, oder? Genau. Ich bin felsenfest davon überzeugt, dass Christopher absolut falsch liegt. Ich habe aber nicht die leiseste Ahnung, welches Argument ich präsentieren muss. Ah, ich schuldige uns. Aber auch tatsächlich eins, wo Christopher hinterher hier anruft und sagt, jetzt habt ihr mich jetzt überzeugt. Ich kenne den, der ist nicht doof. Also intellektuell kann er das absolut nachvollziehen, was wir hier sagen. Aber wie kriegen wir das in sein Herz?
Ja, ich finde es halt sehr, sehr bedenklich, irgendwie so, wie einfach er mit Worten wie Freiheit und so weiter umgeht. Weil, ich denke mal, wenn man sich irgendwie sich vorstellt, wie Leute in China teilweise leben müssen, unter welcher Kontrolle die da stehen, was wir für ein wertvolles Gut haben, dass wir im Prinzip mehr oder weniger noch das tun und sagen dürfen, was wir wollen, ohne dafür direkt irgendwie in den Knast zu kommen.
Christopher geht auch davon aus, dass das in Zukunft auch so bleiben wird.
Ja, das Problem ist einfach, das ist immer so Stück für Stück, was man irgendwie so abgibt davon. Und was ich ganz wichtig auch finde, ist so der Gedanke, was die Privatsphäre eines Einzelnen wert ist dafür, bei dieser verdacht unabhängigen Ermittlung, dass man dann mal unter vielen Tausenden vielleicht irgendwie ein Treffer landet und da wirklich mal einen erwischt, ob es wirklich das wert ist, dass man viele wirklich unschuldige Leute hat, der irgendwie durchsuchen darf.
Also es ist natürlich keine verdachtsunabhängige Maßnahme der Bundestrojaner. Also sie soll schon dann eingesetzt werden, wenn sie Verdächtige haben. Also es ist nicht wie bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, dass einmal alles gespeichert wird, sondern sie werden da schon individualisiert vorgehen und also eine bestimmte Person, gegen die sie auch schon irgendwie was vorliegen haben, versuchen da irgendwie auszuschnüffeln.
Aber es ist ja immerhin immer noch so ein Stück von dem Ganzen dann, was passiert und ich finde halt, man gibt immer mehr und mehr davon ab und irgendwann ist man dann auch in so einer Art Netz gefangen irgendwie durch diese ganzen Maßnahmen, die es da gibt zur Überwachung.
Ja, aber du scheinst dir zu merken, aber andere Menschen merken nicht, dass wir uns schon auf diesem Weg befinden.
Ja, ich glaube, dass das Christoffer so darstellt, irgendwie ist das wirklich, was auch so bei uns verbreitet ist. Und so dieses, es wird schon gut gehen. Wir wissen zwar keine bessere Lösung, weil es steht ja nun mal außer Frage, dass viele Dinge, die nicht in Ordnung sind, sich auch Techniken wie das Internet und so weiter zu nutze machen. Nur wenn man dagegen halt kein Mittel weiß, dann ist es halt das, was der Staat auch macht, was ich finde. Es ist halt so blinder Aktionismus. Man ist halt hilflos, man muss irgendwas tun, aber man weiß nicht was. Und so sehe ich das auch bei den ganzen vielen Sachen.
Der Chat.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung und so weiter. Man sammelt, man macht, man tut, aber man weiß auch noch nicht wirklich, wie man das alles nutzen soll.
Der Chat sagte, wahrscheinlich würde es helfen, wenn Christoph mal staatliche Ungerechtigkeit wieder fährt.
Ja, es ist meistens so, wahrscheinlich erst, wenn man das, was man dann selbst nicht mehr hat, irgendwie auf einmal vermisst, dann weiß man halt, wie viel das wert war. Und solange ihm da nichts passiert ist in dieser Richtung, denke ich, wird er da auch weiter relativ blauäugig mit umgehen. Und ja, meine Angst ist halt auch so ein bisschen, wie das Ganze durchgezogen werden soll. Weil wenn man sich mal anschaut, was teilweise so wirklich als fachlich kompetent irgendwie bei den Entscheidern sitzt, dann kriege ich schon so ein bisschen Angst. Die Wahlcomputer sind ja ein gutes Beispiel dafür. Und wer weiß, wie die da so ein Ding überhaupt aufziehen? Und was ist, wenn auch so Sourcecode und so ein Zeug, der von in die falschen Hände dann gerät? Oder wenn die Teile verteilt sind?
Na zu dem Quellcode hat sich ja der BKA-Chef Zierke jüngst im Bundestag bei diesem Expertengespräch geäußert. Er hat nämlich gesagt, dass dieser Quellcode natürlich gegenüber einem Richter dann offengelegt wird, damit der Richter sich dann diesen Quellcode ansehen kann.
Und der Richter kompiliert sich das ganze Ding und macht wahrscheinlich einen Unitest, bis er sagt, es ist alles in Ordnung.
Kann der Richter sich nicht einen Gutachter dann bestellen?
Na klar kann er.
Das wird dann auch der Gutachter sein, den er immer bestellt, weil er ihn gut kennt.
Zierke hat die Problematik, dass er ja beweisen muss für einen möglichen Bundestrojaner, dass dieser eben nur Daten ausgespät hat und nicht etwa Daten auf diesem Rechner platziert oder manipuliert hat. Und deshalb hat er die Argumentation angebracht, dass er den Quellcode dann ja nachträglich offenlegt.
Ist doch eine tolle Idee.
Ja, es würde uns auch einzigartige Möglichkeiten geben, die Methoden des BKA zu analysieren.
Vor allem, wenn wir dann irgendwie in einem extrem lustigen Gutachterstreit bei jedem Einzelnen dieser Prozesse, weil natürlich irgendwie der Gutachter, das Anwalts des Angeklagten, wird natürlich irgendwie sagen, aber gucken sie doch mal da, da hätte doch irgendwie noch dieses passieren können und da hätten sie noch jene Funktionen benutzen können.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn er einmal den Quellcode offenlegt, dann müssen sie danach hier einen neuen Trojaner schreiben.
Selbstverständlich.
Die haben sie doch nicht mehr alle.
Ja, was auch wiederum zeigt, dass der Herr Zierke, glaube ich, sich von seinen Fachbeamten vielleicht noch mal beraten lassen sollte.
Das Problem, was ich da finde, bei den Fachberatungen, wenn man sich überlegt, was hier in den Umlauf geraten ist, zum Beispiel die biometrischen Pässe. Welcher Fachmann war wirklich da und hat da beraten, bzw. ist überhaupt verstanden worden, was dahinter steckt? Weil das ist alles viel zu optimistisch immer angegangen. Also ich finde, man sollte bei dem leistesten Zweifel, dass so was wirklich nach hinten losgehen kann, sagen, das machen wir nicht. Und das können wir nicht machen, weil das hat das mit Demokratie, mit unserer Freiheit und mit den höchsten Gütern, die wir haben, zu tun. Und das vielleicht hätte ich einfach aufs Spiel gesetzt.
Also bei den biometrischen Pässen wissen wir es mittlerweile. Da war es einfach die Industrie. Die halt genau diese Pässe gerne einführen wollte, um halt irgendwie da endlich mal ein Vorzeigeprojekt zu haben, im großen Maßstab und halt Geld zu verdienen. Und der genosse Minister Schili ist ja jetzt auch im Aufsichtsrat von so diversen dieser Firmen. Was irgendwie, also hat halt den Schröder gemacht. So was Schröder halt mit dem Erdgas macht, der Schili halt mit der Sicherheitstechnologie.
Und Schröder hat ja schon den Müller gemacht, weil was Müller mit der Bundesnetzagentur gemacht hat, der jetzt auch im Vorstand der ARG.
Ja, genau.
Das Problem ist auch, so viele Gutachten, die es auch geben hat, wenn dann Entscheider irgendwie so vom Charakter, wie zum Beispiel des Herrn Schäuble sind, die dann irgendwie wirklichen Fakten auch mit Ignoranz begegnen. Nur weil sie halt denken, irgendwie damit bewegt man vielleicht doch noch irgendwas in die halbwegs richtige Richtung. Kollateralschalten hin und her, das ignorieren wir einfach mal. Wir müssen ja auch irgendwie so ein bisschen was vorweisen können. Solange bringt das irgendwie nichts. Ich finde es bedenklich, wie schnell solche Entscheidungen wirklich durchgehen und dass man nichts dagegen machen kann.
Das Problem ist tatsächlich, dass der einzige Arbeitsnachweis, den ein Beamter bringen kann, und so gesehen sind unsere Politiker dann auch Beamte, ist die Verordnung. Stell dir mal vor, du hast eine Legislaturperiode, in der passiert nix. Kein Geschwätz, keine tollen Ideen, die zu irgendwelchen Problemen führen. Sondern das Land läuft einfach so weiter. Die halten das einfach nur auf Kurs und versuchen nicht den Kurs zu ändern. Da heißt es doch, hinterher haben die ihren Job nicht gemacht. Das heißt, letztlich müssen die ihren Aktionismus verfallen.
Naja, es ist wahrscheinlich doch eher so, dass das Problem, in dem sich verändernden politischen Kultur auch liegt, de facto sehen wir eigentlich bei all diesen Maßnahmen, die wir seit dem 11. September gesehen haben, wir sehen keine Debatte mehr, jedenfalls keine inhaltliche mehr. Sondern es steht im Prinzip von vornherein fest, welches Ziel erreicht werden soll. Und wichtig ist im Prinzip nur noch, wie es auf der Bundespressekonferenz dann präsentiert wird, damit die richtigen Zeitungen, die richtigen Buzzwords eben abdrucken. Also es geht nicht mehr wirklich um inhaltliche Debatte. In der Regel wird die erst nachher geführt und eigentlich auch nur noch mit der Opposition.
Was ich auch noch denke, ist um die Qualität dieser ganzen Maßnahmen. Ich glaube nicht, dass wirklich jemand, der professionell Internet oder neue Medien nutzt, um halt solche Dinge zu planen, keine Maßnahmen trifft, um gegen sowas irgendwie gefeiert zu sein. Also ich denke nicht, da schickt jemand in Klartext irgendwie an sein Adressbuch Hallo, morgen 10 Uhr, Bombe, Karstadt weg oder so.
Große Revolution auf dem Alex.
Ja genau. Wir stürzen den Staat oder so.
Mit Blutvergießen. Bringt alle heran, schuld.
So was einfach irgendwie dann auch einen Sinn hat. Und es wird aber auch niemand von uns hier einschreiten, weil bei Autobahngebühren, das ist kein Ding. Da muss jeder zahlen und sagen, das finde ich nicht sinnvoll, da gehe ich mal, wenn überhaupt, irgendwie auf die Straße. Ich meine, das machen ja auch die wenigsten auch irgendwie mal wirklich auf die Straße zu gehen, wenn irgendwas nicht passt und...
Nee, mittlerweile bloggen wir das alles.
Aber wer liest auch Blogs, wenn man sich das mal überlegt? Die meisten sind ja so die Internetnutzer, also die, die ich kenne, für die ist das Internet. Irgendwie besteht das aus eBay, Google und das, was die beiden Wolfgangs irgendwie erzählen. Das wird dann auch so ganz, ganz leicht, glaube ich.
Echt, du kennst Leute, die sich den Schwachsinn anhören, den die beiden Wolfgangs absondern?
Das will sie selber. Ich hab es mir teilweise auch einfach mal angehört. Ich fand es früher, ich kannte das halt, bevor ich so viel mit Computern und so zu tun hatte.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie Alfred Biolack beim Vergreisen im Fernsehen zuzugucken. Das ist auch nicht schön gewesen die letzten Jahre.
Es ist halt viel Müll, was dabei herumkommt. Das Problem ist dabei, dass die meisten, die wirklich nicht versiert sind und sich das anhören, das auch wirklich glauben. Ihr Wissen aus Computerbild und das, was die beiden Jungs da sagen.
Aber Computerbild geht ja noch.
Ich bin Wahlhelfer gewesen, das ist alles in Ordnung mit den Wahlcomputern. Und auch da wirklich alle Fakten der Kritikpunkte irgendwie ignoriert. Dann sind das viele, die das einfach glauben. Und alles in allem glaube ich einfach auch, dass die Mehrheit nicht die fachliche Kompetenz hat, um zu sagen, ihr schmeißt da unser Steuergeld raus. Deswegen wird das halt geduldet, weil wirklich niemand überhaupt eine Ahnung hat, was hier passiert. Inklusive der beiden Wolfgangs.
Genau, wenn hier irgendjemand eine Ahnung hat, was passiert, dann sind das ja sowieso nur wir.
Ich glaube zumindest, dass es ein kleiner Kreis ist. Und selbst da bezweifle ich auch noch, dass wirklich auch überall die Motivation da ist, dann wirklich was zu bewegen. Weil ich kenne viele, die kritisch zum Thema gegenüberstehen, dann aber auch sagen, ich alleine kann eh nichts bewegen. Und selbst wenn ich mich mit ein paar zusammen tue, das mir die ignoriert.
Interessanterweise haben wir festgestellt, dass die nicht so ist. Also ich meine jetzt gerade so bei diesem Bundestrojaner-Thema haben wir doch irgendwie mit relativ wenigen Leuten schon relativ viel Aufmerksamkeit erzielen können. Also was man schon sagen kann, ist, das ist halt wirklich ein Irrtum. Also wenn man sich tatsächlich hinsetzt und anfängt, Dinge zu machen, kann man halt erstaunlich viel bewegen, wie wir so in den letzten Jahren doch eigentlich immer wieder gesehen haben. Da darf man sich einfach nicht irgendwie vorzeitig verschüchtern lassen.
Also immerhin haben wir den Herrn BKA-Chef Zierke dazu gekriegt, dass er im Prinzip eine Ochsentour in den Medien machen musste, weil er in den letzten zwei Wochen irgendwie mal bei allen Zeitungen und musste da Interviews absondern.
Gab es in irgendeinem der klassischen Medien eine ernstzunehmende kritische Berichterstattung?
Klassische Medien im Sinne von, weiß ich, Tagesschau oder so?
Tagesschau, also sowohl öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk als auch süddeutsche FAZ und so. Also sie haben es nicht bejubelt?
Wir hatten auch sehr viele Kontakte beim Chaos Computer Club jetzt, wo sich einfach Medienvertreter gemeldet haben und insbesondere über die technischen Hintergründe, also was tatsächlich möglich ist, mit diesem sogenannten Bundestrojaner, sich erkundigen wollten. Also da gab es schon eine ganze Menge. Also wirklich klassische Medien.
Achso, ja, was würdet ihr dann konkret vorschlagen, was jetzt so ein Einzelner machen kann halt gegen diese Einführung des Bundestrojaners? Zumindest irgendwie seinen Unmut darüber auszudrücken. Als Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt überlege, ich gehe Montag zur Uni irgendwie und treffe da die üblichen Verdächtigen bei uns aus dem Fachbereich, die alle sagen, ja fürchterlich und finde ich nicht gut. So mehr als vielleicht mal eine Online-Petition unterschreiben, so wüsste ich ganz ehrlich auch nicht.
Also was durchaus irgendwie interessant ist, ist ein bisschen Abgeordnete informieren. Also man ist erstaunt darüber, wie gut die denn doch zuhören.
Brief schreiben?
Wenn sie mal jemanden begegnen, der tatsächlich von dem Fachgebiet, um das es ihnen geht, irgendwie Ahnung hat und sie sachlich und unaufgeregt informiert, sind viele Abgeordnete sehr dankbar, weil sie einfach eine Regel nur gefiltert bzw. halt irgendwie Medieninformation bekommen und halt irgendwie Hintergrundinformation zu komplexeren Themen halt einfach nie in einer Art und Weise aufbereitet bekommen, dass sie die auch verstehen können. Wir haben es halt häufig mit Fraktionszwang zu tun, also gerade bei Gesetzen ist es halt immer ein bisschen schwierig, also da muss man halt schon relativ viele Abgeordnete bearbeiten. Was sicherlich auch hilft, ist zu sehen, ob man tatsächlich Medienkontakte aufbaut bzw. findet. Briefe schreiben, auch an Medien, also Leserbriefe schreiben, ist durchaus eine Sache, die man machen kann.
Naja, man hat noch mehr Möglichkeiten. Also die Kosten heute an ziemlich viele Menschen, seine Meinung zu bringen, gegen null. Also sich in einen Blog irgendwo hinzusetzen oder eben auch eine normale Website Homepage, ist sehr einfach. Also man kann seine Meinung einfach sagen. Potenziell lernen die ganze Welt.
Also was ich immer sehr wichtig finde, ist halt mit normalen Leuten reden. Also mit Leuten, wo es halt immer so ein bisschen schwerfällt, denen halt diese Themenkomplexe nahe zu bringen. In der Regel ist es sehr lehrreich, einfach zu sehen, was diese Leute meinen. Also es gibt ja wirklich viele Leute, die so denken wie Christopher. Und man kann sich daran halt auch einfach sein eigenes Bild einfach ein bisschen mehr präzisieren. Weil man neigt halt in der Regel schon dazu, in so einer Binnenrealität zu leben, wo man halt einfach so diese, sagen wir mal, die Normalbürger in Anführungszeichen halt aus Selbstschutzgründen nicht mehr so richtig wahrnimmt. Man muss aber sich damit einfach auseinandersetzen.
Ähm, wir haben jede Menge Anrufer. Lange nicht mehr so viele Anrufer gehabt wie beim Thema Bundestrojaner. Find ich ganz interessant. Also es scheint doch mehr Leute zu betreffen oder betroffen zu machen, als man sich vorher so gedacht hat. Wir schalten live nach Gelsenkirchen.
Hallo, Patrick.
Patrick, Essen ist fertig.
Wo hören uns die Leute dann alle überall?
In Gelsenkirchen.
Ja, ich höre einen Livestream.
Ist das sehr schön.
Funktioniert?
Ja, natürlich.
Mit dem VLC.
Dafür funktioniert die Webcam nicht über äh...
Die haben wir auch nicht wehgemacht im Gegensatz zu dem Stream.
Ignore die einfach mal und sag, was du sagen wolltest.
Ja, ich hab eigentlich nur eine Frage.
Ich bin da jetzt auch eher laie, aber ich wollte fragen, ob man nicht das Verhalten eines solchen Bundestrojaners in einem für den Verfassungsschutz dann sehr attraktiven Honeypot eigentlich analysieren könnte, um dann Rückschlüsse zu ziehen.
Was heißt das, was du da gerade gesagt hast?
Ja, das heißt im Endeffekt, dass man ein System, das im Netzwerk eigentlich keine Funktion hat, hinstellt und dem einen Zugriff ins Internet verschafft. Also einfach router, portsfrei würde ich sagen. Und da lässt man dann Applikationen drauf laufen, also Programme, ich hab mir überlegt, vielleicht könnte man da einen Webserver drauf laufen.
Ich versuch das jetzt mal in doof.
Sprechen wir noch Bahnhöfe in die Luft, damit die auf einen aufmerksam werden?
Ich versuch das jetzt mal in Holger Kleinisch zu übersetzen. Mit anderen Worten, du stellst einen Rechner hin, der einzig und allein dazu da ist, diesen Bundestrojaner anzulocken, ihm aber garantiert keine verwertbaren Informationen gibt, aber Hauptsache du hast den Bundestrojaner, dann kannst du ihn auseinandernehmen und gucken wie er geht.
Ja, ob man das im Prinzip machen könnte, um nachzuvollziehen, wie man sich dagegen am besten schützen kann.
Ich schätze, das Problem wird sein, den so zu konstruieren, dass sie einen wirklich ernst nehmen. Aber wenn man die größte Bombenbastellibrary im Internet baut...
Ja, dann kommen die schon an irgendwann. Dann kann man diesen Honeypot auch betreiben. Ich meine, die sagen ja, dass sie diesen Trojaner individuell einsetzen wollen und nicht irgendwelche aktuellen Schwachstellen im Betriebssystem ausnutzen und da Würmer los schicken und erstmal alle infizieren.
Sie können die nur individualisiert einsetzen?
Das ist genau der Punkt. Dass die Leute anfangen, die Netze wild abzuscannen und irgendwann auf deinen Honeypot stoßen und sagen, da installieren wir den jetzt. Also das halte ich für nicht so besonders realistisch. Allerdings, es ist letztlich doch nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis dieser Trojaner, wenn es ihn gibt in dieser Form, auf irgendeinem Rechner landet und dort entdeckt wird von jemandem, der ein bisschen Ahnung von hat. Was meinst du, wie schnell dieses Ding irgendwo veröffentlicht ist und wie viele Hacker sich Conteste da ausdenken, um dieses Ding auseinander zu pflücken, die Funktionalität nachzuvollziehen und eventuell selbst Schwachstellen in der Implementierung dieses Trojaners zu finden?
Dazu hat sich aber der BKA-Chef nochmal ganz konkret geäußert. Erstmal hat er postuliert, dass Schwachstellen in dem Bundestrojaner gar nicht vorkommen.
Die sind ausgeschlossen?
Jawohl, Programmierfehler würden seine Spezialexperten keinesfalls machen. Und außerdem hat er natürlich Protokolle geben, dass es keine eigene Verbreitungsroutine für diesen Trojaner geben wird. Und außerdem wird dieser Bundestrojaner ein Datum zur Selbstauflösung haben.
Also ein interessanter Aspekt ist, was immer wieder diskutiert wurde, war die Frage, ob der Staat nicht an irgendeinem Punkt hingeht und die Hersteller von jeweils verbreiteter Software, Stichwort zum Beispiel das ELSTER Programm zur Steuer, zur Abgabe der elektronischen Steuererklärung, ob man da nicht tatsächlich mehr oder minder Strachstellen einbaut, die das relativ einfach machen, dann den Bundestrojaner dazu indizieren. Ich denke mir mal, zum Beispiel bei der ELSTER Software würde ich dann doch irgendwie schon mal nachgucken wollen, weil mittlerweile musst du ja wirklich fast jeder verwenden, der irgendwie Steuererklärung abgibt. Also als Gewerbetreiber musst du halt deine Steuererklärung ja mittlerweile elektronisch mit dieser schlechten Software abgeben.
Das macht mein Steuerberater.
Das gute Risiko, einen Steuerberater zu delegieren.
Darin sehe ich eigentlich das Risiko, dass das Gesetz am Anfang greift, dass wirklich versucht wird individuell darauf eingegangen zu werden, dass man Leute versucht aufzuspüren, die sich wirklich verdächtig verhalten. Dass dann irgendwann gesagt wird, okay, jetzt finden wir nicht mehr genügend Leute, die sind einfach up to date, die wissen, wie sie sich dagegen wehren können. Wir kommen nicht dahinter. Was können wir sonst noch mit dem Programm machen? Jetzt haben wir die rechtliche Grundlage, Online-Durchsuchungen durchzuführen. Was haben wir noch für Möglichkeiten außer dieser Zielgruppe des organisierten Verbrechens und Terrorismus? Und da ist ja wieder der Eindruck in die Privatsphäre, den ich dann auch eher negativ bewerten würde.
Na ja, gut, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie wirklich diesen Bundestrojaner auf größeren Mengen Computer loslassen, ist wohl sehr gering. Weil sie tatsächlich einen Verdachtsmoment gegen eine Person haben, dann müssen sie ziemlich viel wissen über das Computersystem dieser Person und dann müssen sie diese Schadsoftware anpassen an den Rechner, den der benutzt, oder die Rechner.
Wie soll der erst mal auf den Rechner kommen? Der muss da irgendwie hin. Und wenn der Anwender eine Firewall hat und sein System patcht, regelmäßig, und über die aktuellsten Browserversionen und Software benutzt.
Na gut, ich meine, wir wissen, dass es irgendwie...
Dann treten sie ihm die Tür ein und nehmen den Computer mit.
Wenn sie das tun würden, wär das ja in Ordnung.
Die treten die Tür ein und werden einen USB-Stick platzieren.
Wir wissen, dass es im geheimdienstlichen Bereich gibt es Absprachen zwischen den Herstellern und den Geheimdiensten für genau solche Sachen. Da werden in richtigen Komitees, sogenannten Vulnerability-Komitees, Absprachen darüber getroffen, dass bestimmte Fehler erst nach einer bestimmten Zeit behoben werden von den Herstellern. Da gehen die Geheimdienste hin und sagen, pass auf Jungs, wir wissen, dass ihr gerade an diesem und jenem Patch arbeitet. Könnt ihr bitte den noch mal sechs Mal unterliegen lassen, weil wir wollen damit gerade dieses und jenes oder irgendwas tun. In der Regel sind dann halt die großen Systemhersteller da auch sozusagen willens, diesem großen staatlichen Kunden zuzuhören. Und so ähnlich könnte das halt auch irgendwie in Deutschland funktionieren, dass halt einfach die Softwarehersteller sagen, bzw. im Staat angesprochen werden, nicht mal eine Hintertür einzubauen, weil die Software ist einfach scheiße und die wird die ganze Zeit kaputt und hat lauernd Löcher und muss gepatcht werden. Und alles, was nötig ist, um halt irgendwie so ein Trojaner einschleusen zu können, ist im Zweifel halt ein Loch mal eben ein paar Monate ungepatcht zu lassen, weil es ohnehin niemand weiß. Also wenn der Hersteller das Loch selber gefunden hat oder vielleicht sogar der Diensthersteller das Loch selber gefunden hat und nicht gepatcht wird, dann kann es halt benutzt werden.
Ist davon auszugehen, dass der Dienst das Loch findet, bevor es irgendwelche weltweit im Zweifelsfall irgendeinen Hacker findet und veröffentlicht wird?
Die können sie auch einfach abkaufen.
Also es gibt einen großen Markt für solche Löcher, also die werden halt gehandelt. Also wenn du jetzt halt losgehst und sagst, du hast irgendwie einen Zero-Dexploit für Internet Explorer, der halt irgendwie auf dem aktuellen System läuft. Keine Ahnung, was gerade der Marktkurs ist, aber irgendwie so 10.000, 20.000 Dollar kriegst du dafür schon. Und dafür...
Von wem?
Wie auch immer...
Das muss nicht unbedingt ein Geheimdienst sein. Das ist natürlich auch ein großer Markt für Wirtschaftsspionage.
Und auch einfach Sicherheitsfirmen, die sich damit profilieren wollen. Die sagen, wir haben den und den gefunden. Teilweise haben die nur geringe eigene Research-Abteilungen, die solche Fehler finden. Sondern die kaufen die halt einfach dazu.
Ja, eine dicke Börse eben.
Und so kann das halt natürlich auch einfach für einen Start laufen. Da können halt einfach losgehen, solche Fehler, sich kaufen, dem Hersteller Bescheid sagen, pass auf, den Bug lässt du mal sechs Monate ungepatcht, wenn ihn zwischendurch jemand findet, nochmal zufällig, ok, kannst du ihn natürlich patchen, da können wir jetzt nichts gegen tun. Aber in der Regel ist es halt so, dass solche Sachen dann halt einfach lange offen bleiben. So gerade in großen Routern oder TK-Anlagen und dergleichen Dingen, die halt ohnehin selten gepatcht werden, ist sowas gang und gäbe. Und so könnte natürlich dann ein Start auch operieren.
Die Problematik besteht halt immer darin, dass zum einen die Bundesregierung immer sagt, ja, uns ist die IT-Sicherheit, die liegt uns ja wirklich am Herzen, da wollen wir alles tun. Und doch gerade der BSI-Präsident Helmbrich hat in derselben Veranstaltung, in der Zierke ja diesen Bundestrojaner vehement gefordert hat, hat er über IT-Sicherheit gesprochen und darüber, wie man eben Computersysteme besser gestaltet, sicherer. Und wie wichtig diese Maßnahmen für den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland sein. Also das sind halt zwei Strategien, die gegeneinander laufen.
Begreift er das? Also sagt er das wieder besseres Wissen?
Nein, Helmrecht ist natürlich ein Experte. Zierke ist jemand, der sich natürlich technisch nicht versteht, worüber er redet, hat man auch deutlich gemerkt. Wie der in allen Interviews auch.
Also der glaubt wirklich, da fällt irgendwo aus irgendeinem Computer was raus, was er unmittelbar als Ermittlungshilfe nutzen kann.
Ja, und der glaubt auch, dass der Bundestrojaner fehlerfrei sei. Und da war er fest von überzeugt.
Das ist der Chef des Bundeskriminalamts, der höchste Polizeibehörde hier.
Ja, er ist ein Ermittler und kein Informatiker.
Er ist kein Softwareengineer.
Ja, bin ich auch nicht.
Also der Bundesamt für Sicherung in der Informationstechnik BSI ist da natürlich in einer blöden Situation, weil sie sind halt eigentlich dafür zuständig, die IT Bundesrepublik Deutschland sicher zu machen. Aber sie sind halt eine dem Innenministerium unterstellte Behörde. Das ist halt einfach sozusagen der Design-Bug an dieser Behörde, dass sie halt dem Innenministerium unterstellt ist. Deswegen sich dann halt der Chef des BSI auch nur hinstellen kann und sagen kann, wie wichtig die IT-Sicherheit ist. Der kann sich da halt nicht hinstellen und sagen, also Bundestrojaner, ihr habt sie ja wohl nicht alle. Das geht dann halt einfach quasi in Abhängigkeiten da nicht.
Offiziell wollten der Chef vom BSI und der Chef vom BKA auch gar nicht gemein sein bei diesem Gespräch.
Das ist doch mal was. Einfach mal ein Interview mit beiden. Das wäre mal was für die Kollegen hier im Tagesvolk. Macht mal, Kollegen macht mal ein Interview mit beiden und konfrontiert den einen mit dem, was der andere sagt, ohne dass der eine es weiß. Ja, das ist doch hinzukriegen.
Nein, das ist einfach gemein, weil Helmrecht ist ja jemand, der darüber Bescheid weiß.
Dann soll er es sagen. Dann soll er den Schneid verdammt nochmal haben, sich da hinzustellen und zu sagen, mein Dienstherr baut gerade eine riesengroße Scheiße. Und wenn es ihn den Job kostet, dann kostet es ihn den Job. Den Mumm müsste man vielleicht mal haben.
Ja, den müsste man haben, aber dann ist man vielleicht nicht Chef von BSI.
Ja, das kann natürlich sein. Ich meine, es sagt sich natürlich auch leicht, wenn man nicht selber in der Situation ist. Aber was ist dann der Mann wäre?
Das ist halt immer die Abwägung, wie viel Gutes kannst du in der Position tatsächlich noch tun, wenn du halt gelegentlich Kröten schluckst.
Die Frage ist, wie dick die Kröte ist, die du da schluckst mit diesem Ding.
Ja, das war die Frage.
Wir machen Nachrichten. Patrick, vielen Dank.
Diesen Song. Und diesen Song. Und diesen Song. Könnt ihr bald live hören. Denn wir haben die passende Band dazu. Freitag, 6. Ab 20 Uhr in der Kolumbiale Berlin.
Mehr Infos fritz.de.
Mit Grisha Sidelke.
Das iranische Staatsfernsehen hatte Aufnahmen einer britischen Soldatin und ihrer ebenfalls festgehaltenen Kameraden ausgestrahlt. Die britische Regierung bezeichnete die Ausstrahlung der Aufnahmen in einer ersten Reaktion als inakzeptabel. Premierminister Blair sagte, die iranische Führung müsse begreifen, dass sie sich in völliger Isolation befindet. Die Satellitenbilder belegen nach Ansicht des britischen Verteidigungsministeriums, dass die Marineangehörigen nicht in iranische Gewässer eingedrungen sind. US-Präsident Bush hat dem russischen Präsidenten Putin Gespräche über den umstrittenen Raketenschutzschild angeboten. Er sei bereit, Russlands über Details des Abwehrsystems zu informieren. Das teilte die russische Regierung mit. Putin habe seinerseits dem US-Präsidenten die Bedenken Russlands gegen die geplante Stationierung von US-Raketen in Polen dargelegt. Die Spitzengespräche der großen Koalitions- und Thema Mindestlöhne sind beendet. Nach der Runde im Kanzleramt gab es keine Erklärungen, da Vertraulichkeit vereinbart worden war. Damit blieb offen, ob sich Union und SPD in den koalitionsinternen Dauerkonflikt angenähert haben. Die SPD will gesetzliche Mindestlöhne für weitere Branchen durchsetzen und über das Entsendungsgesetz regeln. Die Union lädt verwendliche Mindestlöhne entschieden ab. Zum Sport Fußball. Die deutsche Nationalmannschaft hat ihr Test. Länderspiel gegen Dänemark mit 0 zu 1 verloren. Und Basketball. Cup-Verteidiger Albert Berlin ist im Viertelfinale des deutschen Basketballpokals ausgeschieden. Alber unterlag 69 zu 74 bei Rheinenergie Köln. Wetter. In der Nacht gibt es ein paar Wolken. Regnen soll es aber nicht. Die Temperaturen gehen auf 6 bis 1 Grad runter. Am Tag wird es wieder sonnig. Allerdings kommen mehr Wolken durchs Endegebiet. Unvereinfindend kann es auch mal regnen. Das Ganze bei maximal 17 Grad. Der Verkehr auf Ritz, A12, Berliner Ring, Richtung Frankfurt oder zwischen Frankfurt oder Mitte und dem Grenzübergang Frankfurt oder gibt es Stau. Das Steuende liegt derzeit bei Kilometer 57. Ansonsten sind die Straßen frei und wir wünschen euch eine gute Form. Warum lachst du da?
Wer das Steuende findet, darf es behalten. Genau. 23.33. Vielen Dank, Richard.
Ritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz in Spremberg.
Chaosradio 122 der Bundestrojanen.
Rock'n'Roll!
Das kann Frank erklären, der hat es angeschleppt.
Ja, ich dachte mir, wenn wir schon von Trojanern reden, können wir von Ohrwürmern reden. Was war das? Das Lied. Ich glaube, Konziz am Rechner.
Das hieß Ritter Rost, der Prinz von Katalanien.
Der Prinz von Katalanien. Der verschenkt Granien. Ihr hört Chaosradio 122, der Bundestrojaner ist unser Thema. Und wir telefonieren und telefonieren. Ihr könnt auch gerne die eine oder andere qualifizierte oder unqualifizierte Frage an unsere Experten stellen. Diese Experten bin nicht ich, sondern diese Experten sind Kronstein, sind draußen und Frank. Robin aus Heilbronn. Du hast so deine eigene Theorie.
Ja, was heißt Theorie? Das wäre ja einfach mal so aufgegriffen. Es ist ja noch nicht angesprochen worden, dass diese ganze Kampagne auch vielleicht irgendwo ein bisschen auf Einschüchterung der Bürger abzieht, weil letztendlich, ich meine, das Medium Internet ist ja so weit präsent, dass ja der Staat jetzt auch sagen muss, okay, nicht aufmucken, sonst weiß man ja, hatten wir ja auch schon beim Lauschangriff so ein bisschen. Ich denke mal, da möchte man einfach, der Staat möchte so ein bisschen Kontrolle haben über das Medium. Ich zweifle einfach ein bisschen an den Argumenten von dieser Kampagne. Man sagt ja einerseits Terrorverdächtige ausfindig machen. Da frage ich mich, warum man das Ganze eigentlich so großartig ankündigt. Ich meine, die meisten Terrorfahndungen, die laufen doch wirklich unter verdeckter Hand. Wir wollen ja nicht die paar Terroristen, wenn es in wirklich welchem Deutschland gäbe, wirklich vorwarnen, dass sie jetzt ihre Daten runter schaufeln. Außerdem sind die ja auch nicht blöd, die werden sich ja sicherlich anpassen. Ich denke mal, wir haben ja gesehen aus der Vergangenheit, die sind ja auch relativ gut organisiert. Und ich denke einfach, ja, das ist in meiner Ansicht nach ein bisschen schwach.
Ich glaube aber eigentlich, dass Ihnen blöd dazwischen gekommen ist. Also weil Sie haben ja schon praktisch ohne gesetzliche Grundlage oder auf nur imaginierter gesetzlicher Grundlage bisher schon agiert. Und dann kam Ihnen ja halt dieser Richter am BGH dazwischen, der gesagt hat, dafür reicht einfach die gesetzliche Grundlage nicht aus. Und dann ist ja tatsächlich jetzt die Diskussion entstanden.
Also praktisch geht der Streit darum schon über zehn Jahre. Also diese Juristen, die sich da so streiten, das ist sehr lange schon auf eine alte Entscheidung von 1994 zurück. Ihnen ist quasi mit dem BGH-Urteil vom Februar dieser Thema auf die Füße gefallen, ohne dass Sie tatsächlich wollten. Und natürlich haben Sie sich jetzt auch nicht gefreut, dass es diese Anfrage gab, nach den Möglichkeiten, die die Geheimdienste haben, in den Bundstrojanern. Sie haben keine Kampagne gestartet, sondern Sie mussten sich im Prinzip gegen die Kritik wehren.
Ja, gut, es war ja irgendwo klar, dass es dann wirklich so viel Medienaufmerksamkeit haben wird. Ich denke mal, damit war ein bisschen zu rechnen. Das ist einfach so vielleicht wirklich so eine kleine Botschaft nach dem Wunder Big Brother is watching you, weil die Argumente, also jetzt sagen wir vielleicht auch mal Gewaltverbrecher, wie ja bereits angesprochen werden, die planen das ja nicht wirklich im Vorausgleich mit MS Project oder was weiß ich was alles. Das sind ja auch teilweise spontane Aktionen oder Affekthandlungen. Also da sehe ich eigentlich auch nicht wirklich Argumente dafür, wie man jetzt zum Beispiel Gewaltverbrecher aufhalten sollte. Und was Kinderpornos angeht, das ist ja ein ganz, denke ich mal, schlagfertiges Thema. Da soll man doch bitte einfach wirklich aber knallhart ohne Gnade gegen die Betreiber vorgehen. Und ich denke mal, dazu sollten auch ein paar Mittel sein. Und wenn jetzt die Länder hier international ein bisschen kooperieren, da gab es ja auch schon einige Erfolge, dann sollte das doch auch zu meistern sein, sage ich mal. Ich meine, andererseits hatten wir ja auch ganz wirksame Methoden, wie die Rasterfahndung bei den Kreditkabendesitzern. Das hat sich ja wohl durchaus als effektiv gezeigt. Also da hat ja der Staat schon...
Und das hat es nicht. Das genaue Gegenteil ist passiert.
Du meinst jetzt diese Aktion Mikado?
Also jetzt ironisch gemeint, sage ich ja mal, inwiefern das jetzt wirklich rechtlich okay war. Das kann man jetzt sehen, wie man will.
Da wird auch erst vor Gericht momentan festgestellt.
Ironisch gemeint ist es natürlich, ja sicher, da war es effizient. Es hat tatsächlich eine Wirkung gezeigt, sagen wir mal so. Also es hat eine Wirkung gezeigt und mit irgendeinem Trojaner wäre diese Wirkung wahrscheinlich nicht verbessert worden. Im Sinne der Strafverfolgungsbehörden verbessert.
Vielleicht mal ganz jetzt ein bisschen auch auf das Thema Terrorismus wirklich fokussiert. Also ich habe jetzt selber als Bürger von Deutschen keine Angst vor Terroristen. Ganz einfach aus dem Grund, weil sobald ich mich jetzt von Terroristen unterdrücken lasse oder auch von dem Staat, der dann dieses Argument anbendet, und dafür meine Freiheit ein bisschen einschränken lasse, dann habe ich die Terroristen ja eigentlich schon gewinnen lassen. Weil die werden sich ja auch, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber die würden sich ja auch ein Asterblatt. Und sagen wir mal, wenn wir den normalen Bürger, der eigentlich jetzt nichts zu verbergen hätte oder so, da die Freiheit dementsprechend einschreitet, dann hatten die ja auch an einer anderen Stelle Erfolg, sag ich mal. Also letztendlich heil ich von der Kampagne jetzt nicht sonderlich viel. Ich seh auch nicht wirklich, wie das jetzt großflächig technisch machbar sein soll, weil die Terroristen dann sich sicherlich anpassen. Und für die breite Masse ist es natürlich nicht geschaffen. Aber ich denk mal, die Zeit wird zeigen, ob daraus jetzt was wird, oder ob es dann letztendlich dann doch vom Bundesverfassungsgericht eingeschränkt wird. Das kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen, da muss man einfach abwarten. Es geht mir eigentlich nur mal wirklich um den Aspekt, dass man vielleicht wieder versucht, irgendwo den Bürger ein bisschen zu schikanieren, zu sagen, ja, bloß nicht aufmucken. Und letztendlich ist es ja noch eine Frage der Zeit, bis jetzt die erste Software oder Hardware rauskommt, die dann sagt, ja, wir blockieren den Trojaner nur 1995 oder sowas. Also jetzt vielleicht mal von der anderen Seite ein bisschen gesehen. Ich meine, ob das sinnvoll ist oder nicht, ich halte es nicht so sinnvoll zur Anmerkung von dem Christian, würde ich noch kurz sagen. Christopher, ja, genau, weil ich das ja auch live verfolgt habe. Ich denke mal, er hat einfach eine Meinung und das sollte man halt auch irgendwo respektieren, auch wenn es jetzt in mancher Ansicht vielleicht nicht ganz begründet ist. Aber ich denke mal, jeder hat halt seine Meinung und jeder hat halt auch sein Recht drauf. Ich meine, da kann man sich drüber aufregen, sollte man aber nicht, lohnt sich nicht.
Da geht es gar nicht ums Aufregen, sondern es geht darum, was ich eben schon gesagt habe, ich bin der festen Überzeugung, dass er falsch liegt. Und zwar absolut falsch. Und die Frage ist ganz einfach, wie lautet ein mögliches Argument dafür, ihm klar zu machen, dass er falsch liegt? Oder meinetwegen auch das Argument, mir klar zu machen, dass ich falsch liege?
Ja, ich denke mal, du liegst auf keinen Fall falsch. Das ist ja auf jeden Fall, man sieht ja, es ist ein sehr kontroverses Thema. Und ich denke mal, die Meinung dagegen überwiegen. Es war ja vielleicht auch mal nicht schlecht, mal jemand zu hören, der dagegen ist. Aber ja, also auch wenn man jetzt sagen würde, die Argumente sind nicht vorhanden. Aber ich denke mal, man kann jetzt manchen Leuten nicht wirklich in den Kopf rein drücken. Nee, das ist was Böses oder so. Da hat halt jeder seine Meinung. Und ich denke, jeder hier hat auch ein unterschiedliches Level von technischem Wissen sozusagen. Manchen ist vielleicht nicht bewusst, was für ein Spektrum das Ganze annehmen könnte. Weil wenn wir sagen, wir machen jetzt den Bundestrojaner, auf was läuft das jetzt vielleicht in ein paar Jahren hinaus.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du da technischen Sachverstand für brauchst, um beurteilen zu können, dass es im Grunde darum geht, jedes einzelne Dokument, jede einzelne Datei, die sich auf deinem Computer zu Hause befindet, einfach mitzulesen. Ja, doch, ich glaube schon, dass man gewissen technischen Sachverstand... Meine Eltern haben überhaupt keinen technischen Sachverstand. Die haben noch nicht mal einen Anrufbeantworter.
Ja, aber du müsstest es ihnen erklären.
Ich würde einfach sagen, was die Vorhaben ist, sie wollen jede einzelne Datei, jedes einzelne Foto auf deinem Computer, der da im Keller steht, wollen die sich angucken.
Aber Bezirke hat entgegen, dass das ja auf gar keinen Fall passieren wird, weil sie werden nur mittels Schlagwörtern suchen. Und also wenn du deine Bombenbastel-Anleitungen nennst, Liebesbrief an Uschi, dann werden sie darauf nicht zugreifen, weil das wären ja dann Privatdokumente.
Gut, das wird sich ja zeigen. Ich denke mal jetzt noch mal zu dem technischen Level. Ich meine, es gibt so viele Leute in Deutschland, die geben schon so viele Daten raus, ohne überhaupt den Umfang zu kennen. Also geben wir mal YouTube, Blogs oder so was. Oder jetzt meinetwegen auch Leute, die dann irgendwelche Tauschbörsen umlaufen haben. Ich denke mal, viele geben da einfach unwissen Daten frei. Das ist ja auch nochmal ein technisches Verständnis, das vielleicht nicht da ist, weil sich manche doch nicht bewusst sind, was für einen großen Umfang das Internet halt hat. Wenn man jetzt mal wirklich so weit gehen würde und sagen, ok, wir haben jetzt eine technische Grundlage, um Leute zu überwachen. Ohne jetzt mal zu sagen, ok, jetzt genau auf die oder die, ob das jetzt rechtlich ok ist oder nicht. Wenn man jetzt in ein paar Jahren sozusagen sich das so weit sensibilisiert hat, dass man vielleicht irgendwann mal sagt, ok, wir passen das Gesetz an, weil es vielleicht doch erhöhte Terrorgefahr, von der ich mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht beeindrucken lasse. Also ich lasse mich jetzt von den Terrorern nicht einschüchtern und bin auch nicht bereit, wenn es mal irgendwann so weit kommen sollte, mir meine Freiheitsrechte dadurch einschränken zu lassen. Weil wie gesagt, wenn ich, es gibt ein Zitat, das ich in solchen Sachen gerne mal erwähne, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Herr Benjamin Franklin kennt. Genau, der hat ja mal gesagt, also es war einer der Gründervater der USA, er hat ja gesagt, he who would trade liberty for some temporary security deserves neither liberty nor security. Übersetzt für alle, die nicht des englischen Mächtigsten, sage ich jetzt mal, also diejenigen, die wirklich bereit sind.
Übersetzt es einfach.
Ja, also diejenigen, die bereit sind, Freiheit für temporäre Sicherheit aufzugeben, die verdienen weder Freiheit noch Sicherheit.
In diesem Sinne, schönen Dank Robin.
Ja, ganz blöde Frage, der Herr Bundestrojaner, ne, wie heißt der Mensch?
Zirze oder Zirke?
Genau, Zirze.
Mal abgesehen, dass er mit seiner Prozentrechnung ganz schön daneben gehauen hat. Er erklärt, 99, 99 Prozent müssen nicht befürchten, bleiben immer noch 8.000, 800 Leute übrig.
Ganz schön viel für einen individualisierten Bundestrojaner.
Und jetzt geht es aber los. Er will das Ding individualisieren. Das Ding muss individualisiert werden, vorausgesetzt, es wird das geben. Das heißt, ich muss eigentlich ziemlich genauer Kenntnis über das Rechnersystem haben, in das ich eindringen will.
Na, derjenige, den du durchsuchen möchtest.
Oder schicke ich vorher doch schon irgendwelche Sachen, wie gesagt, gezielte Angriffe auf den Rechner, auf die Reise, um rauszufinden, wie der Rechner reagiert und wie auch immer. Und ist denn in der Zeit zwischen der Ausspionierung der technischen Möglichkeiten des anzugreifenden Rechners und der Installation der Überwachungstools nicht einfach so viel Zeit, dass eventuell der Kollege mal ganz schnell einen anderen Rechner verwendet hat und das alles nicht funktioniert. Also irgendwie habe ich so meine Zweifel. Oder kommen sie doch in die Wohnung, geheim, ohne mir das zu sagen, eine Art geheimer Hausdurchsuchung, untersuchen meinen Rechner dann ganz geheim und installieren das Ding sozusagen solange ich nicht da bin.
Aber wie wollen die das denn machen? Die haben das Passwort gar nicht, um das Ding zu booten.
Vielleicht kann Thorsten mal kurz...
Das ließe sich, denke ich, mal mit einer eingelegten CD. Kriege ich so einen Rechner schon mal gebootet. Und wenn ich nicht das komplette Datalsystem verschlüsselt habe, kann ich doch vermutlich auch irgendwas einspielen.
Vielleicht kann Thorsten dir mal kurz erklären, wie das heutzutage funktioniert.
Na ja, also man kann schon Informationen sammeln über so ein System. Aber das kann man nicht mit einem Schuss machen. Man kann nicht einfach mal nachgucken und weiß dann alles. Das ist eben eine Informationssammlung, die man über einen längeren Zeitraum betreiben kann. Aber das ist eben auch genau die Frage, ob dann eben, wenn der Trojaner dann endlich fertiggestellt ist, ob der Terrorist sich da nicht vielleicht ganz anderen neuen Computer gekauft hat, ganz anderen Betriebssystem. Das ist halt einfach das, was die ganze Sache so unrealistisch macht. Man muss halt über einen extrem langen Zeitraum genau diese Information sammeln, denn man will ja nicht auffallen. Man kann sich diese Information schnell zusammensammeln, aber das ist doch auffällig. Wer Terrorist kann sich ja auch jeden Tag ein anderes Internetcafé setzen.
Oder er könnte die Daten beispielsweise auf seinem Rechner zu Hause mittels Tonschuhnetzwerks sammeln, an den gar keiner rankommt von außen.
Also ich unterbreche euch ja nur ungern, aber es hört sich immer so an, als würde es den sogenannten Bundestrojaner gar nicht geben. Es gibt ihn. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass sie ihn erst erfinden wollen. Er wird ja eingesetzt und das Bundesinnenministerium hat es auch schon zugegeben.
Ja, also gut, was sie da tatsächlich tun im geheimdienstlichen Bereich, also wenn ich jetzt mal von ausländischen Vorkommnissen auf Deutschland schließe, ist, dass sie da halt sich einfach Abteilungen von Leuten hingesetzt haben, die halt wissen, wie man den Rechner aufmacht.
Die gehen halt gezielt gegen eine bestimmte Zielperson vor, aber die installieren nicht irgendeine generische Drutkette auf dem Rechner.
Sondern die haben halt einfach einen großen Werkzeugkasten und nehmen halt was passt.
Genau und das ist eigentlich das, was wir unter dem Begriff Bundestrojaner entzucken, verstehen müssen.
Das sind einfach die rechtlichen Grundlagen, die geschaffen werden, auch Kollateralschäden in Kauf nehmen zu können, ohne dafür belandet zu werden. Weil Kollateralschäden entstehen einfach auch bei der Recherche. Oder ich meine, selbst wenn du an deine Zielpersonen nicht direkt rankommst, die hat Freunde, dann gehen wir eben auf die Rechner von den Freunden. Die sind schlechter gesichert. Da gibt es ein Vertrauensverhältnis zwischen den Leuten und den Rechnern.
Geheimnis hier Informationsbeschaffung ist ja nun nichts Neues. Das ist ja keine Erfindung des Informationszeitalters, die gab es ja auch schon früher. Da musste man das ja eher noch, sagen wir mal, genauer betreiben als heutzutage. Dass man dann sozusagen irgendwie das Umkreis beginnt zu untersuchen, Verknüpfungen beginnen zu untersuchen. Deshalb müssen wir ja schließlich jetzt auch lange Zeit unsere Telekommunikationsdaten sichern, damit man das ja auch lange genug noch untersuchen kann. Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich habe so meine Schwierigkeiten immer noch damit, dass das wirklich so geheim geht, das Gerät, also diese Überwachungstour, dann wirklich geeignet anzupassen. Und ich habe so meine Schwierigkeiten mit der Aussage des BKA Menschen, dass er sagt, also wir suchen nach Schlagworten.
Ja, damit wollt ihr ja im Prinzip klar machen, dass sie keinesfalls in diesem von den Juristen Kernbereich der privaten Lebensgestaltung genannten, sehr intimen Bereich...
Vor allen Dingen hat der Bundesinnenminister doch selbst irgendwo, den habe ich doch auf einer Pressekonferenz oder in einem Interview sagen hören, dass man natürlich die Liebesbriefe durchsuchen muss, weil natürlich die bösen Terroristen auch bei den Terroristen natürlich wüssten, dass sie das nur in privater Post tagen müssen. Entweder lügt da jemand oder jemand hat es überhaupt nicht begriffen.
Der Ziel gesaß hat in einem Kreis von Datenschützern im Grunde und war also auch an der Verteidigungsposition und ihm fiel dann offenbar nichts besseres ein oder sein Einfluss daran, eben die Sache mit den Schlagmottern anzubringen, um einfach von vornherein klar zu machen, nein, nein, also sie machen da keinen datenschutzrechtlichen Schmuck, sondern sie suchen eben nur nach Schlagmottern.
Nur nach Nullen und Eins.
Also gut, ich fühle mich also eher wesentlich unsicherer als sicherer dadurch. Ich finde meine Meinung, das ist eine der tiefgreifendsten Änderungen derzeit in dem recht, in dem freiheitlichen Recht, was man mir vorhält, dass es existiert, was es seit der Erfindung oder seit dem Übergang für mich in dieses staatliche System gegeben hat.
Naja, nun ist doch aber der Plan, dass auch für diese Online-Durchsuchung ein Richtervorbehalt vorgesehen ist, sowie eine nachträgliche Benachrichtigung, wenn du jetzt als Betroffener abgeschnorchelt würdest. Wäre das für dich ein probatet rechtsstaatliches Mittel?
Nein, nein.
Weil?
Keineswegs, weil ich mir einfach zu viele Gedanken mache, selbst wenn wir mal davon ausgehen, die Kollegen machen, Kollegen, Vorsicht, die Herren machen das richtig, oder Damen machen das richtig. Und sammeln also wirklich nur eine bestimmte Anzahl von Daten. Was sie daraus herauslesen, ist ja immer noch was ganz spannendes. Nummer angenommen, ich hab ja nochmal Physik studiert, also interessiert mich doch dieses und jenes, beispielsweise auch über Waffentechnik. Genau, lagert man ja auf dem Rechner.
Der hat uns angerufen. Schön, jetzt werden wir alle abgeschnorchelt, weil du hier angerufen hast.
So ist es. Ihr müsst jetzt also dringend eure Kommunikation verbergen und woanders hin verlagern. Ja, so was sammelt sich nun auf meinem Rechner. Die Frage ist, was passiert denn jetzt damit? Ist ja denn jetzt der Meinung, ich bin der bitterböse Terrorist, weil ich irgendwie drei Webseiten darüber zusammengeklickt habe? Oder weil ich das Buch vom Herrn Clancy im Schrank zu stehen habe, wo er es mal ziemlich ausführlich drin beschreibt, wenn ich den Kerl auf Ansonsten ziemlich hasse. Ich hab da so wirklich meine Zweifel. Also daher, ich bin grundsätzlich der Meinung, dass eine derartige Informationssammlung eine derartige hohe Fehlerquote beinhaltet, dass es mir dabei ganz, ganz schlecht wird, wenn ich an deren Umsetzung denke.
Danke, Axel. Gute Nacht, tschau.
Gute Nacht, tschüss.
Wir haben jede Menge... Wir schalten nach Berlin, ausnahmsweise. Obwohl Axel war ja auch in Berlin. Peter aus Neukölln.
Peter?
Hallo?
Der ist schon weg.
Peter?
Ah, dann sag doch was.
Ja, hier, ich höre euch.
Sprich, du bist dran.
Jo, im Radio. Ja, mein Stichwort. Ich hatte es eurem Redakteur gesagt, dass ich jetzt eigentlich so in der Diskussion, die ich jetzt auch schon ziemlich detailliert mitverfolge, schon länger, noch nicht aufgetaucht ist. Nämlich, ähm, Sabotage.
So.
Erstmal ganz pauschal.
Also, kannst du mal ein Beispiel geben?
Ja.
Also, wie ich den Bezug, ist zu wenig ein Beispiel. Nämlich, ähm, Bundestrojaner, der wird ja nun, sag ich mal, auf meinem Rechner installiert. So. Und damit wird er ja in einem gewissen Maße beeinflusst. Sprich, ein bisschen Performance gehts flöten, ein bisschen Sicherheit gehts flöten. Ist jetzt auch gar nicht entscheidend, wie viel, sondern nur die Tatsache als solche. Das heißt, wer sowas rechtlich machen darf, will, konjunktiv, braucht das Recht dazu, Sabotage zu verüben. Jetzt mal ganz pauschal gesagt.
So. Aber der Zirk gesagt doch, dass sie gar nicht hacken und dass die Trojaner alle gar keine Malware sind, gar keine gefährlichen Hacker Tools, sondern einfach nur, ja, da sind die Sicherheit in diesem Land zu erhöhen. Das sind alles ganz normale Computerprogramme.
Die freundliche Bundessuchmaschine auf deinem Rechner?
Ja gut, soweit zur Theorie, ja. Worauf ich raus will, ist ja sozusagen dieser Aspekt, dass da jetzt ein neues juristisches Feld aufgetan wird, nämlich, dass eben dieses Recht theoretisch eingeräumt werden müsste, wenn dieses gesetzlich erlaubt werden sollte, müsste die Erlaubnis zur Sabotage erteilt werden, weil es das ja faktisch ist.
Es werden auf jeden Fall Daten manipuliert und das ist ja eigentlich auch ein Punkt, der juristisch manipuliert.
Nein, nicht manipuliert, sondern mein Rechner wird beeinflusst.
Da gibt es die einschlägigen Straftaten und Computerstrafrecht, das ist Manipulation von Daten, Ausspielen von Daten, Überwinnen von Sicherheitseinrichtungen. Sie würden sozusagen die gesamten Katalogstraftaten des Computersicherheitsstrafrechts de facto den Ermittlungsbehörden freistellen, so wie sie heute mit blau und rot über die Ampel fahren dürfen. Das wäre tatsächlich die Folge. Die interessanten Nebenaspekte, das hast du ja schon angesprochen, sind natürlich zum Beispiel, was passiert, wenn Sie auf dem Weg zu meinem Rechner noch andere Rechner beschädigen oder was passiert zum Beispiel, wenn Sie das Ding inkompetenterweise auf einem Rechner installieren und der dabei irgendwie abstürzt und das zufällig meine Firmen datenbank. Und ich bin irgendwie für zwei Wochen out of business und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Also man begibt sich da irgendwie auf ein juristisches Feld, was hochgradig heikel ist. Wenn Sie mir bei der Hausdurchsuchung meinen Computer beschlagen haben, dann habe ich halt irgendwie in gewissem Umfang halt irgendwie Möglichkeiten, mich dagegen zu wehren und von denen weg abzukriegen und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Genau, wenn Sie aber hingehen und mir bei einer heimlichen Durchsuchung mein Computersystem kaputt machen, dann gehe ich natürlich eigentlich erst mal mindestens von einem Computerangreifer aus. Was passiert denn, wenn ich jetzt anfange zurückzuhacken? Und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Sollen wir vielleicht mal ganz ganz generell sagen, wo der Unterschied liegt zwischen einer normalen Hausdurchsuchung und dieser sogenannten Online-Durchsuchung.
Es wundert mich, dass das bisher noch keiner angesprochen hat. Dass man das mal direkt miteinander vergleicht. Was für Rechte hat man bei einer normalen Hausdurchsuchung? Welche Rechte kann man hier gar nicht wahrnehmen?
Also zunächst mal ist es ja so, dass es natürlich keine verdeckte Maßnahme ist, weil man ja schon deshalb, was sie bei einem klingeln, darüber Bescheid weiß. Man braucht natürlich auch für eine Hausdurchsuchung einen richterlichen Beschluss. Sprechend wird richterlich zuvor geprüft, ob die Maßnahme eben geeignet ist und notwendig und zumutbar. Oder Gefahr im Verzug. Richtig, aber das wäre eine Eilrichterentscheidung. Als nächstes hat man das Recht, sich einen Zeugen zu nehmen, damit man eben von der dritten Person bestätigen lassen kann, dass hier alles mit rechten Dingen zugeht. Und zum Beispiel eben nicht eine Tüte Koks platziert wird, sondern dass man eben noch jemand hat, jemand anderes, der zuguckt.
Kann ich in dem Moment, wo die bei mir vor der Tür stehen und sagen, Hausdurchsuchung, sagen, bitte warten Sie, bis mein Zeuge hier ist?
Und dann hätte man zum Beispiel danach auch ein Protokoll. Ja, auch praktisch.
Also wenn es Ihnen zu lange dauert, dann holen Sie halt noch irgendjemand von der Straße oder den Nachbarn, dass ein Zeuge dabei ist, dass ein formaler Requirement erfüllt ist. Und bei einer Regel, wenn Sie jetzt irgendwie nicht bei dir 25 eingesperrte, minderjährige Prostituierte vermuten, dann sind Sie schon durchaus willens, darauf zu warten, dass dein Anwalt auch da ist.
Man muss sich das nicht so vorstellen wie im Fernsehen, dass da irgendwie die Schwerbewaffneten eindringen, sondern das ist eher eine ruhige Aktion. Sie beschlagnahmen eben, was sie beschlagnahmen wollen, und gut. Und man kriegt vor allen Dingen nachher ein Protokoll, sodass es eine dokumentierte Sache ist. Und hier ist es eben so, dass dieser Begriff Online-Durchsuchung, zwar irgendwie suggeriert, da würde jetzt auch eine Durchsuchung stattfinden, aber ganz grundsätzlich ist es eine andere Maßnahme. Zum einen ist es eben heimlich, und zum anderen ist es auch eine dauerhafte Maßnahme. Und zwar dauerhaft in dem Sinne, dass es eben nicht eine Momentaufnahme ist, also wo sie eben einmal in die Wohnung kommen, mitnehmen, was sie wollen, sondern dass es eben ein Programm ist, was auf jeden Fall eine Weile auf meinem Rechner ist. Wie immer die Selbstauflösungssequenz dann da aussehen wird und ob es die geben wird, auf jeden Fall ist es eine dauerhafte Maßnahme.
Ja, aber die kann es doch gar nicht geben. Also ich meine, das Ding kann sich doch nicht selbst auflösen.
Doch, doch, du kannst schon.
Ja, natürlich kann sich das löschen, aber woher will das Ding denn wissen, dass es jetzt genau die richtigen und genug Erkenntnisse gesammelt hat?
Na, wenn es ein Trojan ist, kann es ferngesteuert sein.
Okay, aber dann brauchst du keine Auflösungssequenz.
Das ist jetzt nur ein Schlagwort.
Entschuldigung, ich wollte nur...
Das ist ein neues Buzzword.
Also das, ich glaube ich irgendwie nicht so sehr an den Dingen, die dieser Herr, der sich seinen Fachbeamten vielleicht mal etwas mehr Zeit zuwenden sollte...
Lustig war das der Professor Fitzmann im Leben.
Aber das ist doch, Entschuldigung, ich hab doch nochmal die Frage. Was ist mit diesem Mann von, was ist mit diesem BKA-Chef los? Ich verfüge auch nicht über großartig technisch Sachverstand, sondern was ich anwende ist simple, wahrscheinlich nennt man das Logik. Also kann der noch nicht mal das oder will der noch nicht mal das?
Sein Job bei dieser Veranstaltung war, Propaganda zu verbreiten. Dafür ist er der BKA-Chef.
Der ist der BKA-Chef dafür, dass er Verbrechen aufklärt, die begangen werden. Dafür wird er von seinen Steuergeldern bezahlt und nicht dafür, dass der Mist erzählt.
Entschuldigung, ich verstehe mich schon wieder auf.
Ich mach jetzt mal mein Mikrofon zu.
Nein, also diese Veranstaltung, also wenn man jetzt von dieser Bundestagsveranstaltung bei den Grünen, also weil eigentlich ein Expertengespräch ausgeht, dann muss man einfach sagen, dass der BKA-Chef dort eine, also sehr innerheitsreiche Litanei abgelassen hat, über alle möglichen Bedrohungen, die uns in Zukunft, also irgendwie alle bedrohen werden eben. Sein bestes Schlagwort war eigentlich, dass man das Internet, der jetzt eigentlich gar nicht mehr Internet nennen sollte, sondern Virtualer Dschihad. Also man muss sich fürchten, dass er da... Doch, das hat er gesagt. Ich hab's mir aufgeschrieben. Virtualer Dschihad, also der Punkt ist, dass er einfach, er hat ganz viele verschiedene Szenarien. Also das war nicht nur Kinderporn und organisierte Kriminalität, sondern er hatte auch gleich noch Geldtransfers, fremde Geheimdienste, Rechtsextremismus. Er hatte Bomben, er hatte Fishing, er hatte Anschlagsplanungen, Selbstmordattentate und Pädophile. Mehr kann man sich schon kaum noch in der kurzen Zeit, die er gesprochen hat, irgendwie reinbringen. Also er hat einfach versucht, ein großes Potenzial an tatsächlichen Straftaten dahin zu malen, so als Streckensszenario, um dann klar zu machen, so und jetzt brauche ich dringend dieses ganz wichtige Tool.
Wer kontrolliert den BKA-Chef?
Am Ende wahrscheinlich wirklich nur das Bundesverfassungsgericht wieder, wenn der Bundestarium zuhört.
Ja, das Argument.
Das Argument, genau. Was ich jetzt auch ableite, sozusagen, aus dieser Sabotagegeschichte. Nämlich, dass so wie ich ihn verstehe, hat er irgendwie so die Idee von so einer Art idealen Staat. Das heißt, das sind alles irgendwie die vertrauenswürdige Leute. Also Polizisten, etc. PP, Politiker und so weiter, die alle das machen, was in den Gesetzen drin steht, um ihn da irgendwie zu schützen.
Also das ist im Prinzip genau die Denke, die auch circa an den Tag liegt. Also zunächst ist mal jeder verdächtig. Das ist sozusagen dieser Rangehensweise an andere Menschen.
Du meinst, das ist genau entgegengesetzt dem, was der BKA-Chef annimmt. Also für den BKA-Chef ist jeder fertig, für Christopher ist jeder erstmal unverdächtig.
Genau. Also das ist natürlich einfach auch eine Haltung, die man gegenüber Menschen einnimmt.
Ich meine, wenn ich heute zum Beispiel wieder Nachrichten höre, gut, jetzt war es halt von der Siemens war einer korrupt, okay. Vor einer Woche war es halt einer hier aus dem Amt oder was weiß ich. Ich meine, das sind Menschen, die werden bestochen, die sind korrupt und die machen Schweine rein. Die gibt es überall. Die gibt es in der Politik, die gibt es beim Polizisten, die gibt es beim Verfassungsschutz. Also einfach zu glauben, ich gebe denen einfach mal so Macht in die Hand. Die dürfen da einfach mal so schnüffeln und so. Und naja, die werden schon das richtige machen. Das ist einfach nur naiv. Also dieses, ich habe nichts zu verbergen heißt, ich verberge so lange nichts, bis ich irgendwie auf die Fresse kriege, weil doch der Falsche irgendwie die Kommission gekriegt hat über mich.
Ich habe nichts zu verbergen heißt im Grunde auch, ich habe echt ein armes Leben.
Das ist einfach nur naiv. Weil es gibt immer irgendjemanden, der irgendwas gegen mich haben will. Egal ob ich jetzt, deswegen muss ich nicht kriminell sein oder irgendwas böses getan haben. Es kann einfach nur der Nachbar sein, der irgendwie andere Meinungen hat oder was weiß ich. Oder jemand hat dummerweise irgendwo Einfluss bekommen.
Oder du gehst zur Musterung und versuchst dich ausmustern zu lassen. Da gab es doch auch letztens so eine Meldung, dass Musterungsdaten vom Kreiswehrersatzamt an Krankenversicherungen gegangen sind. Wo eben rauskam, dass, ich meine, da gehen die Leute hin und versuchen sich krank zu stellen und zu sagen, ich bin zwar erst so und so vier Jahre alt, aber mein Rücken und meine Knie sind schon so kaputt, oder meine Leber, oder was weiß ich, ich nehme Drohungen und was weiß ich. Und das kriegen heutzutage Krankenversicherungen.
Da müssen nur einen kleinen Gebührinsatz zahlen und da halten sie die gewünschte Informationen.
Aber man hat ja nichts zu verbergen.
Dann können sie halt ablehnen, die Versicherungspolizei auszuzahlen im Schadensfall.
Das heißt, meine Krankenversicherung weiß im Zweifelsfall, dass ich damals das Kreiswehrersatzamt beschissen habe, als ich gesagt habe, meine Knie seien kaputt.
Oh oh, wird doch schlimm mit der Lebensversicherung.
Ihr macht jetzt noch Beispiele, wo ihr selber irgendwie gemautelt habt. Funktioniert da genauso andersrum. Jemand, der sie einen Vorteil verspricht, weil er selber eben von eurer Ehrlichkeit profitieren will. Und zu eurem Nachteil natürlich.
Danke, Peter.
Genau. Bitte.
Und gute Nacht.
Tschau.
Chaosradio 122, wie es hier konstanziert. Pass auf mein Zeichen heißt so viel wie nicht jetzt, hörst du das? Ja, das ist falsch. Mach mal aus. So, was gibt es dazu Lachen?
Das weiß ich auch nicht.
Dürfen wir mitlachen? Nee, okay, dann dürfen wir nicht. Ich übe noch ein bisschen. Jetzt legst du dein Wunschlied bereit. Bereit, jetzt hebe ich meine Hand. Auf mein Zeichen hab ich ja eben gesagt. Hand heben heißt Achtung. Jetzt tun wir einfach mal so, als würde gerade das Jingle so auslaufen. Als würde gerade das Jingle so auslaufen. Das macht jetzt mal der Thorsten. Thorsten, machst du jetzt mal bitte... Chaosradio 122, der Bundestrojaner ist unser Thema. Ich liebe dich, Constanze. Was hast du gesagt? Immerhin hab ich dir dabei in die Augen geguckt.
Evil dick! Dick! Evil dick.
Hier ist Chaosradio 122. Die Drogenabhängigen haben ihre Drogen genommen. Genau, der junge Herr, der hier diesen entsetzlichen Husten hat, der selbstverständlich nicht vom Rauchen kommt, sondern eine chronische Bronchitis ist, die er sich irgendwann mal eingefangen hat, als er in einem kalten Baggerloch schwimmen war, ist jetzt auch wieder hier im Studio. Der Bundestrojaner ist unser Thema. Und wer ist denn am Till? Ich muss jetzt gerade mal ein bisschen gucken, wer hängt denn schon lange in der Leitung? Der Rainer, hallo Rainer.
Bin ich jetzt in der Leitung?
Du bist dran, ja.
Ich muss schon sagen, ich hab hier über eine Stunde lang das Telefonhüter am Ohr gehabt und ich hab schon einen steifen Nacken. Echt?
Warum hast du nicht mal so ein Ohr gewechselt?
Das hab ich natürlich gemacht.
Na los, dann hast du jetzt die Chance.
Dann kriegst du jetzt genau 30 Sekunden Zeit.
Das finde ich unfair.
20 Sekunden.
Zum Christopher mit dem Politikvertrauen. Da kann ich nur eins sagen. Gesamtdeutsche jüngere Geschichte, da hat man für einen schlechten Witz Konsequenzen gehabt. In der DDR damals hatte man für einen schlechten Witz auch mit Konsequenzen zu rechnen. Wie sieht es heute aus? Das wäre von der Geschichte lernen. Es war eine andere Sache, ob man dem Staat noch vertrauen kann. Auf der einen Seite haben wir hier den Wirtschaftsraum EG. Die nationalen Grenzen sind abgebaut. Und jetzt haben die so viel Angst vor angeblich vor allen, also vor allen Bewohnern der EG-Zone, dass wir alle Terroristen sein können, dass wir überwacht werden müssen. Dieses Beweisrecht ist da glaube ich irgendwie umgekehrt worden. Oder dieses Verdachtsrecht. Wir sind ja alle schuldig. Und nicht unschuldig. Dann die Sache ist, mit der, wie ihr den vielleicht überzeugen könnt, oder wie ihr ihm noch mal einen Denkansturz verpassen kann, erscheint er sich irgendwie auch mit Informatik ein bisschen auseinandergesetzt zu haben. Und das stelle ich mal, ein bisschen technisch. Und die Information an sich ist ja neutral. Es ist die Frage, wie ich die Schablone anlege, wer die Schablone anlegt und wer sagt, was falsch oder richtig ist.
Also wer definiert die Norm, nach der du bestraft wirst de facto?
So, und ob man den Politikern vertrauen kann, es gab hier in Berlin letzte Wochenende in einer Zeitschrift einen ganz kleinen Artikel, Seite 30, so in einer Innenseite oder irgendwo. Nagel mich bitte nicht auf die Zahlen fest, dass angeblich 400 oder 600 Politiker hier in der Bundesrepublik von der Staatsanwaltschaft übersucht, überprüft werden. Man könnte dazu sagen, Vorteilnahme im Amt oder Bestechlichkeit. Ach so viel zum Start.
Hab ich nicht mitbekommen. Weißt du noch, wo du das gelesen hast?
Tagespiegel. Sonntagausgabe.
Na ja, was für Politiker geht, dass sie unschuldig sind, so lange bis sie verurteilt sind.
Na ja, also ich meine, wir hatten ja schon mal den Ansatz zu sagen, denn so Politiker haben ja notorisch nichts zu verbergen, weil sie sind ja Politiker sozusagen, Menschen des öffentlichen Rechts. Aber viele von ihnen sind ja eigentlich Problempolitiker. Und so als Problempolitiker ist man ja eigentlich, hat man eine gewissermaßen höhere Kriminalitätsneigung als der Rest der Bevölkerung. Aber leider habe ich dazu irgendwie keine Daten gefunden. Insofern muss ich das nachher nochmal aussuchen.
Na aber Schäuble hat gesagt, er ist anständig.
Guck, der hat ja auch noch nie den Bundestag genommen. Bitte was?
Darf ich mal zu dem Mann im Rollstuhl was sagen?
Zu Wolfgang Schäuble, dem Bundesinnenminister meinst du?
Der Mann hatte doch vor kurzem mal gefordert, oder seit kurzem kommt wieder häufiger die Forderung auf, dass man die Bundeswehr auch im Inneren einsetzen will.
Ja, das ist ja ein Projekt von zehn Jahren schon. Das will er ja schon seit Jahren.
Da fragt man sich, wer wen schützen soll. Die Bundeswehr, die Politiker, damit die weiterhin das Volk betrügen und ausnutzen können, um sich von dem Konzern bezahlen zu lassen, wie es ja bei einigen Politikern anscheinend der Fall zu sein scheint, um es mal ganz vorsichtig zu formulieren. So, und wie Informationen oder wie manipuliert wird, möchte ich euch beiden oder euch allen mit dem Christopher nochmal den Spiegel vor das Gesicht halten. Es ging da eine ganz kurze Momentaufnahme, eine hitzeige Diskussion mit dem Konas. Die Frage ist, egal wer das ist, war er der Christopher oder wart ihr bei dem Konas, habt ihr mit ihm gesprochen oder wart ihr in der Zeit, als der Konas irgendwo im Ausland war? Keiner von euch als Partei. Er war durch die Berichterstattung als Redakteure, so wie sich das anhörte für mich, pro Konas. Und Christoph hatte da gegenüber seine Bedenken.
Christoph hat eigentlich deutlich gemacht, dass er findet, dass sich der Moral Konas einfach in den falschen Kreisen bewegt hat und dass er deshalb mit Strafe rechnen muss. So hat er eigentlich argumentiert.
Ja, er war aber solange er unschuldig ist, also für den Angeklagten pro Konas und er war dagegen. Wenn ich jetzt so polar regieren darf. So und damit ist quasi das doch für euch ersichtlich, wie ihr der Information und der Frittierung von Information unterliegt. Keiner von beiden Parteien war real bei dem Konas dabei. Keiner kann sagen, genau durch eigene Beobachtung und eigenes Erleben, was da passiert ist.
Ja sicher, das Argument kannst du immer bringen. Also ich muss schon voraussetzen, dass ich dem, was er eben dort ausgesagt hat, ich ihm glaube. Also du kannst immer sagen, ich bin bei den meisten Dingen im Leben nicht dabei, sondern erfahre es eben durch die Medien in diesem Fall, durch den Untersuchungsausschuss.
Ja, können wir denn, ich gehe jetzt nicht unter Untersuchungsausschuss, sondern in die Medien. Können wir denn den Medien überhaupt noch glauben?
Ja. Also wir sind auch in den Medien.
Ja, können wir, genau, wir sind nämlich auch, wir sind gerade die Medien.
Ein Teil der Medien.
Egal, jetzt gerade sind wir die Medien. Und du kannst sie nicht über einen Kamm schenken. Du kannst nicht sagen, ja ihr seid ein Teil, dem glaube ich aber dem Rest nicht, darum kann ich den Medien nicht glauben. So funktioniert das nicht. Und ich glaube sehr wohl, dass du den Medien noch glauben kannst, da wird sehr viel Mist gebaut. Da wird sehr viel Schindluder getrieben. Da wird sehr viel nicht berichtet. Da fließen sehr viele Zuwendungen. Auch mittelbare Zuwendungen, die dazu führen, dass bestimmte Berichterstattung stattfindet. Bestimmte Berichterstattung nicht stattfindet. Aber alles in allem kannst du den Medien, zumindest denen, für deren Unabhängigkeit du Quarund-Funkgebühren bezahlst, so weit trauen, dass eine Berichterstattung über Murat Kurnas bestimmt nicht in irgendeiner Form tendenziös ist. Das ist eher das, was wir hier machen, gefärbt tendenziös. Aber das kannst du.
Ich habe da meine Bedenken.
Ja, dann bring mal einen begründeten Zweifel vor und sei nicht einfach misstrauisch.
Ihr wollt doch auch das misstrauen mit eurer Sendung und dem Thema...
Ich möchte den begründeten Zweifel dafür hören, dass du den Medien nicht vertrauen kannst. Genau, einen begründeten Zweifel. Und nicht, da ist einmal gelogen worden, das ist das, was wir mit Wolfgang Schäuble machen. Wir sagen, Wolfgang Schäuble ist ein Lügner, der hat nämlich den Deutschen Bundestag belogen, als es um die Parteispenden ging, und darum vertrauen wir ihm nie wieder. Das ist eigentlich schon eine Unverschämtheit, dass wir das tun. Noch nicht mal das ist ein begründeter Zweifel eigentlich, sondern das ist einfach nur Misstrauen aufgrund von was weiß ich was. Es ist immer sehr leicht zu sagen, den Medien kann man nicht vertrauen, naja, die Politiker sind alle korrupt.
Moment, die Kritik. Es ging bei Christopher da so ein bisschen den Angelhagen zu finden, dass er sich mal so ein bisschen kritisch überdenkt. Und bei mir ist es auch die Kritik. Es ist jetzt ein ganz heißes Eisen. Ich möchte da nicht in das Detail gehen. Wenn hier in Deutschland in den Medien berichtet wird, dann ist das über die bösen Nazis in Anführungsstrichen. Ja, sind nicht alle Nazis und es sind auch nicht alle Neonazis. Aber bei dem Verhalten, dass der Staat an den Tag liegt, dass er die Unzufriedenheit des Bürgers fördert, ist es doch kein Wunder, wenn immer mehr Leute sich überlegen, Rechts zu wählen.
Doch ist es. Es ist ein Wunder. Nämlich jeder, der die NPD wählt, ist ein Nazi. Jeder, der die NPD wählt, ist ein Rassist. Er wählt nämlich eine Partei, die Rassismus als ihre Aufgabe sieht und in ihrem Programm stehen hat. Das hat nichts mit Protest zu tun, sondern das hat was mit einer Haltung zu tun.
Ich habe als Bürger keine Alternativen.
Das ist mir egal, wenn die alternative Rassismus heißt. Wenn die alternative Rassismus heißt.
Das ist eine Unterstellung von dir.
Wenn du die NPD wählst, dann heißt für dich die Alternative Rassismus. Ganz einfach. Die NPD ist eine Partei, die rassistische Parolen propagiert. Und wenn du sie wählst, bist du ein Rassist. Ganz einfach.
Moment, bitte ich noch mal wegen dem Beispiel. Keine der Parteien stellt irgendwie eine inhaltliche Alternative für mich, dass ich sagen kann, ich will jetzt endlich mal einen Grundlohn haben.
Ist Rassismus für dich eine inhaltliche Alternative zu allem, was du sonst hörst?
Es ist, es ist in Anführungsstrichen, es wäre vielleicht die einzige Möglichkeit, meine Stimme dadurch so zu äußern, dass ich sage, ich bin mit dem, was bisher alle anderen Parteien machen, nicht einverstanden. Und deshalb würde ich wählen. Ob ich jetzt mit dem Inhalt dieser Partei einverstanden bin, ist eine ganz andere Sache.
Dann unterstelle ich dir sogar Dummheit, mein Lieber. Dann unterstelle ich dir Dummheit, Rainer. Wenn du das wählst und es ist dir egal, was die für Inhalte haben, einfach nur um deinen Protestausdruck zu verleihen, dann solltest du vielleicht lieber gar nicht wählen gehen. Weil dann bist du nämlich nicht in der Lage, dir eine Meinung zu bilden, die zu einer Wahlentscheidung führt.
Meine Meinung ist, dass ich keine Alternative habe und kritisch gegenüber dem ganzen System bin.
Und das kann man mit Rassismus ganz prima hinkriegen, ne? Einfach mal ein bisschen Ausländer verdreschen.
Du schiebst mich in eine Rassismus-Ecke.
Wenn du NPD wählst, dann bist du mit rassistischen Parolen einverstanden. Ganz einfach. So einfach ist das. Wenn ich Grün wähle, dann bin ich mit, wenn ich, nicht für uns, für alle. Die NPD liest dir durch, was die NPD möchte, guck dir an, was die NPD äußert. Da ist Rassismus drin. Wenn du es wählst, dann machst du dir Rassismus zu eigen. So einfach ist das. Da kannst du auch dich auch überhaupt nicht rausdiskutieren, weil du meinst, das hätte irgendwas mit Protest zu tun. Wenn ich die Union wähle, wenn ich die FDP wähle...
Entschuldigung, bitte sagen, geh bitte auf die Straße und frage den einen oder anderen Menschen, was er von der Politik oder von dem Staat hält. Der Bundestrojaner ist jetzt für euch medientechnisch umsatzfördernd für die Hörer eine Möglichkeit, einen Aufreißer zu finden.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Wie du meinst, also quasi Fritz macht sich jetzt irgendwie einen dicken Umsatzplus, weil er den Bundestrojaner ins Programm nimmt? Wie meinst du das?
Für euch als Thema, das ist interessant. Ihr habt selber gesagt, dass ihr sehr viele Anrufe habt. Ich habe selber eine Stunde warten müssen, um bei euch ranzukommen.
Worauf willst du gerade hinaus, Rainer?
Das ist Chaosradio, was hier Umsätze angeht.
Dass ihr auch immer aufbleibt, von denen ihr ausgeht, dass die interessant sind und dass die euch einen Anfall von Zuhörern bereitet.
Natürlich, wir möchten Leute primär informieren und ihnen vielleicht gegenüber die Informationen, die sie sonst aus den Medien haben, eine Alternative anbieten. Also wir versuchen halt, das Thema möglichst umfassend darzustellen.
Aufklärung.
Gut, nur ist bei der Aufklärung jetzt noch eine Frage gekommen. Ist jetzt da überhaupt mal im konkreten technischen Detail von eurer Seite als Informationen rüber gekommen, wie man sich jetzt dagegen schützen kann? Weil angeblich besteht er ja schon und wird eingesetzt. Es sei denn, ich hab jetzt nicht richtig hingehört. Gibt es von euch eine Anleitung oder habt ihr bisher das gemacht, wo für den normalen Bürger, der von EDV, von Computern, keine keine Wissen hat?
Ja, Thorsten vorhin gesagt, dass jemand, der sein System regelmäßig patcht, immer die neuesten Softwareversionen benutzt und wahrscheinlich sogar noch einen Router laufen hat, wo eine Firewall drauf ist, was die meisten Leute, die zumindest WLAN zuhause haben, machen, dass bei denen sowieso kein Durchkommen ist für so einen Bundestrojaner, zumindest so, wie sie sich das jetzt gerade vorstellen.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Das hat er so nicht gesagt. Du weißt ja nicht, ob es da eventuell noch Sachen gibt, die dein Betriebssystemhersteller nicht weiß oder du nicht weißt. Also ich sage nicht, dass es unweich ist. Man kann den Angriffsvektor natürlich deutlich verkleidern und die Chance verringern, dass man davon leicht betroffen wird. Man stellt Angreifern oder eben dem Staat ein paar Hirnen mehr auf.
Die Frage ist, gibt es überhaupt eine so simple Lösung, wie Rainer sie jetzt gerne hätte?
Ja klar, Stecker ziehen. Also wenn du Informationen hast, von denen du nicht möchtest, dass sie da rankommen, dann betreibst du die auf einem Rechner, der keine Netzwerkinterfaces hat, also nicht ins Internet oder in irgendwie sonstigen Netze gehen kann, weder über Modem, noch über Ethernet, noch über Waveline und verschließt die Daten auf der Festplatte.
Na gut, das müsste ich aber auch um ganz sicher zu gehen, nachher meine Funkmöglichkeit aus dem Computer ausbauen oder nicht?
Das ist der Fall.
Musste abwägen.
Also das ist halt, wenn du halt, also im Hochparanoidenbereich, wo Leute damit rechnen müssen, dass sie einen wirklichen, ernsthaften Angriff von Seiten des Geheimdienstes ausgesetzt sind, ist es tatsächlich so, dass die Informationen, die besonders wichtig sind, nicht auf Computern verarbeitet werden, die irgendeine Verbindung zum Internet haben. Das ist halt einfach, eher Gap ist da halt, also Luftspalt zwischen dem bösen, feindlichen Internet und dem Computer ist da das einzige, was funktioniert.
Keine schöne Aussicht, ne?
Die Sache noch mal zurück mit dem Wählen, von wegen nicht wählen. Wenn die ganzen, wenn der größte Teil der Bevölkerung, der Bevölkerung von der Bundesrepublik mit der Politik nicht einverstanden wäre, dann müssten alle Leute nicht mehr zur Wahl gehen.
Richtig. Weil da... Bevor sie, bevor sie eine rassistische Partei wählen, müssten sie das tun. Ja, ganz genau.
Damit die bestehenden Parteien keine Legitimation mehr haben, uns weiter zu...
Haben sie trotzdem...
.verarbeiten.
Richtig. Vor allen Dingen, wenn das die einzige Gegend, wenn das das Einzige ist, was verhindert, dass Rassisten an die Macht kommen, dann sollte keiner mehr wählen gehen, richtig. Aber dann gehen eben die Freunde der Rassisten wählen und dann kommen die an die Macht. In diesem Sinne, guten Abend Rainer.
Die großen Fußballer von jetzt haben auch mal ganz klein angefangen. Und mit Fritz kann man heute schon mal die großen Fußballer von morgen sehen. Fritz präsentiert den Nike Premier Cup. Das Fußballturnier Deutschlands bester C-Jugendmannschaften. Mit den C-Jugendkicker von Hertha BSC, Berda Bremen, den VfL Wolfsburg und 13 weiteren Teams. Der Nike Premier Cup. Jetzt schon die Fußballstars von morgen sehen. Ostas, Samstags und Sonntags jeweils ab 9 Uhr auf dem Olympiagelände direkt am Berliner Olympiastadion. Mehr Infos fritz.de Deutschlands beste C-Jugendmannschaften beim Nike Premier Cup. Der Eintritt ist frei.
Nachricht mit Grisha Sidelke.
Das iranische Staatsfernsehen hat Aufnahmen einer britischen Soldatin und ihrer ebenfalls festgehaltenen Kameraden ausgestrahlt. Die britische Regierung bezeichnete die Ausstrahlung der Aufnahmen in einer ersten Reaktion als inakzeptabel. Premierminister Blair sagte, die iranische Führung müsse begreifen, dass sie sich in völliger Isolation befinde. Satellitendaten belegen nach Ansicht des britischen Verteidigungsministeriums, dass die Marineangehörigen nicht in irakisch-iranische Gewässer eingedrungen sind. US-Präsident Bush hat dem russischen Präsidenten Putin Gespräche über den umstrittenen Raketenschild angeboten. Er sei bereit, Russland über Details des Abwehrsystems zu informieren. Das teilte die russische Regierung mit. Putin habe seinerseits den US-Präsidenten die Bedenken Russlands gegen die geplante Stationierung von US-Raketen in Polen dargelegt. Die Spitzengespräche der großen Koalition zum Thema Mindestlöhne sind beendet. Nach der Runde im Kanzleramt gab es keine Erklärung, da Vertraulichkeit vereinbart worden war. Damit blieb offen, ob sich Union und SPD in dem koalitionsinternen Dauerkonflikt angenähert haben. Die SPD will gesetzliche Mindestlöhne für weitere Branchen durchsetzen und über das Entsendungsgesetz regeln. Die Union lädt verbindliche Mindestlöhne entschieden ab. Zum Sportfußball. Die deutsche Nationalmannschaft hat am Abend ihr Testspiel, Testländerspiel gegen Dänemark mit 0 zu 1 verloren und Basketball. Cup-Verteidiger Alba Berlin ist im Viertelfinale des deutschen Basketballpokals ausgeschieden. Alba unterlag mit 69 zu 74 bei Rhein Energie Köln. In der Nacht gibt es ein paar Wolken. Regnen soll es aber nicht. Die Temperaturen gehen auf 6 bis 1 Grad runter. Am Tag wird es wieder sonnig. Allerdings können mehr Wolken durchs Sende geweht werden. Dazu vereinzelt kann es auch mal regnen. Das Ganze bei maximal 17 Grad. Der Verkehr Fritz, Berliner Zahn, die Märkische Allee ist zwischen der Kreuzung Pölchio Straße und wie? Pölchio.
Was ist hier los?
Pölchio.
Wie heißt die jetzt?
Pölchio Straße. Was hast du gesagt? Nee, wir fehlten eh da drin, deshalb. Ah, Pölchio gesagt?
Ja, genau Pölchio Straße.
Pölchio Straße. Also ist die Straße mit diesen komischen Regenjacken.
Okay. Öffentlich-rechtliche Sende Disziplin. Die Märkische Allee ist zwischen Kreuzung Pölchio Straße und der Kreuzung Allee der Kosmonauten in beiden Richtungen, wegen eines Unfalls, gesperrt. Ansonsten sind die Straßen frei und wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Richard, vielen Dank Konstanze, vier Minuten und halb.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5 dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder...
Wie ist noch gleich diese Straße?
Wir haben intensiv Rächerchen betrieben.
Pölchhausstraße.
Können wir Ari noch mal einschalten, damit auch die Autofahrer es finden können? Was hast du gesagt?
Also Pölchhausstraße.
Kerner macht?
Pölchhausstraße.
Chaosradio 122, der Bundestrojaner in der Pölchhausstraße ist unser Thema. Constanze ist die Blendengöttin des Abends. Wohingegen wir Jungs hier nur russische Industrieblenden hinkriegen. Constanze, Ktunk, Premiumblenden. Wenn ihr es so übertreibt, dann glaube ich, russische Industrieblenden aus Kanonenstahl.
Sieht ja schließlich im Osten nicht, oder?
Genau. Wohingegen die Constanze, die macht ECMI-Blenden.
Wenn ihr es so übertreibt, dann glaube ich, euch das nicht glaubt, dass auch keiner am Radio ist.
Napperlederblenden sozusagen.
Hallo Martin.
Hallo.
Aus Donauwörth. Das ist in Bayern, oder?
Ja, ein ganz, ganz doofes Kaff.
Was machst du da?
Komm da weg.
Ja, werde ich auch bald.
Gut.
Dann darfst du jetzt mitreden.
Du hast doch nicht unbedingt einen bayerischen Dialekt.
Ja, ich weiß, ich komme auch nicht ursprünglich aus Bayern. Ich komme nicht aus eurer Gegend.
Ach so.
Ja, ich bin zwangsweise hier runtergezogen.
Ein Rucksackbayer?
Du bist runtergezogen, weil es hier keine Arbeit gibt hier?
Nein, nicht deswegen, weil meine Eltern da früher runtergezogen sind und die haben sie mir geflüfft.
Na gut, aber mal deine Privatgeschichten beiseite.
Ach, es war gerade so gemütlich.
Ich habe mir hier ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben. Das ist sehr interessant für mich zum Beispiel bezüglich der staatlichen Kontrolle. Das wird auch noch ein Extremes. Erstens sind wir angekommen und haben gemeint, wir tun jetzt auf alle Internetfähigen Rechner erstmal eine GEZ-Gebühr draufschmeißen. Dann wissen wir zumindest schon mal, wer alles im Rechner hat mit Internet. Dann können wir da unsere Programme, unsere Trojaner-Programme draufschmeißen. Das war auch schon mal ein Vorteil. Und so geht das mal weiter. Und dann neuerdings mit dem Japan, mit dem Torbrunnen, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, wo die Leute gezwungen wurden, einen Code einzubauen, damit sie dann die Hintertür aufmachen, dass sie da reinkommen und wissen, wer was und wo surft. Gut, Kinderpornografie ganz klar. Da sollte man schon gegen agieren, aber da sind auch viele Geschichten aufgetaucht. Ich hab ja davon mal gelesen, dass die da nicht nur an Kinderpornografierer gegangen sind, sondern auch andere kriminelle Taten mit aufdecken haben wollen.
Naja, ich will mich ja ganz sicher nicht als Verteidigerin von Kinderpornografen aufschwehen. Aber es ist im Grunde so, dass sie ewig immer über schwer Kriminalität geredet haben. Und rein strafrechtlich fällt Kinderpornografie nicht darunter.
Gut, würde ich schon darunter legen.
Das ist halt nur besonders widerlich insofern.
Also es ist moralisch schon sehr verwerflich.
Es ist halt immer ein guter Türöffner. Was denkst du, was die eigentliche Motivation dahinter ist? Naja, also einfach hinter dem, was du beschreibst, dass halt einfach so eins nach dem anderen kommt, irgendwie Vorratsdatenspeicherung und so weiter und so fort. Was glaubst denn du, weswegen diese Innenpolitiker das tun?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Das ist sehr zu beantworten, weil die, ich glaube, die machen das so kompliziert absichtlich, damit da niemand wirklich durchsteigen kann. Würde ein schöner Anhaltspunkt für Datenspülernage einfach sein. Dadurch, dass sie jetzt den Bundestrojaner im Gesetz quasi verankern, können sie dann natürlich Firmen wunderbar ausspülen. Ach, ihr habt jetzt zwar eine Firma, das hab ich gar nicht gewusst, einem sorry, zumal ich ein paar Daten gehabt hab, weil sie zurück kamen, lol.
Mein Problem ist, wenn man so mit diesen Politikern spricht, oder einfach mal ein paar Aufsätze von denen liest, die jetzt nicht so irgendwie Tagespropaganda sind, sind die meisten von denen jetzt nicht strunzdorf. Sondern die haben ja durchaus häufig eine Motivation, wo man ihnen unterstellen kann, dass sie neben Machterhalt möglicherweise auch noch irgendwie zumindest irgendeine Art von Interesse verfolgen. Also sie irgendeine Vision haben, weswegen sie Dinge tun. Und was ich halt versuche zu verstehen ist, wieso versuchen die tatsächlich einen Überwachungsstaat zu bauen, ohne diese Abwägung, für die sie bezahlt werden und für die sie gesetzlich verpflichtet sind, irgendwie auch nur im Ansatz durchzuführen. Ok, Schili war jetzt relativ einfach. Der hat jetzt einfach einen Batzen Kohle von einer Biometrier-Nust herbekommen.
Ich kann dir vielleicht mal ein Beispiel erzählen von unserer Übergabe von diesem Bundestrojaner. Wir hatten da so einen gebastelten Bundestrojaner auf der CeBIT. Wir haben ja versucht, diesen Bundestrojaner letzten Dienstag an den Verfassungsschutz NRW, also von Nordrhein-Westfalen, zu übergeben.
Ihr habt ein Pferd gebastelt?
Kann man im Netz sehen, das ist ein schönes Bild.
Man kann es muss einfach gucken, das ist der Wikipedia-Eintrag für den Bundestrojaner.
Das ist quasi ein Spielpferd, über den wir schwarz-rot-gold eingestrichen haben. Wir haben einen schönen Bundesadler bekommen und den wollten wir übergeben an den Verfassungsschutz. Weil wir die Aktionen vorher angekündigt haben, weil wir die am Stand ja auch nicht überfallen wollten, haben wir halt vorher die Gelegenheit benutzt, also Andi und ich, mal mit diesen beiden Leuten vom Verfassungsschutz zu reden. Und ich denke, man merkt da doch sehr deutlich, dass die ganz ernsthaft glauben, woran sie denken, weil der Punkt ist der. Er hat sofort argumentiert mit dem Worst-Case-Szenario. Er hat gesagt, so, jetzt stellen sie sich einmal vor, also wir hätten vor 9-Eleven, also vor den Anschlägen, mit Hilfe unseres Bundestrojaners, diese schrecklichen Anschläge verhindern können. Das ist die Denkweise dieser Leute.
Hast du gesagt, haben sie aber nicht?
Nee, da kam noch ein lustiger Witz, weil Andi hat ihm entgegnet, ob sie denn wirklich an diese 9-Eleven-Theorie glauben. Und er hat sich da leider verperrt und gesagt, nein, da glauben wir auch nicht dran. Also es war halt sehr lustig, weil er sich verplappert hat. Und Andi sagt, nein, nein, natürlich nicht. Und dann mussten wir erstmal alle lachen.
Das BKA glaubt nicht an die 9-Eleven-Erklärung? Wir gehen mal davon aus, dass das eine Privatmeinung ist.
Das ist eine sehr Privatmeinung.
Aber hier sieht man die Szenarien, die sie aufbringen, wo sie auch tatsächlich, zumindest war das mein Dafürhalten, tatsächlich glauben, dass sie mit ihren Tools da irgendwie was machen können.
Grundlos werden sie das auch nicht machen. Allerdings bezweifle ich, dass die Leute das nötige Verständnis und das nötige Wissen aus dieser Materie überhaupt haben. Weil, wie du schon gesagt hast, bezüglich den Routern, wenn du einen Router hast und da halbwegs vernünftig den eingestellt hast, dann kommen die damit nicht weit.
Nee, nee, warte mal. Also da hast du das Argument. Ihr macht das schon missverstanden. Ich will es dir ganz deutlich sagen. Auf deinem Rechner kann wohl ein Bundestrojaner, wenn sie wirklich wollen. Also du musst nicht glauben, dass wenn du mal einen kleinen Nutfirewall hast und die Patches immer artig einspielst, dass du nicht betroffen sein kannst.
Man kann seine Sicherheitsmechanismen, die man sich da installiert, auch falsch interpretieren.
Seitdem es Windows 98 SE kam, habe ich sowieso kein anderes Betriebssystem drauf. Also XP kommt auf keinen Rechner drauf. Und das ist ja super.
Unsere ältere Betriebssysteme und so mehr Sicherheitslücken sind eh bekannt. Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht für den Bundestrojaner.
Natürlich, 98 ist nicht schlecht. Allerdings habe ich halt den Vorteil, dass ich unter XP einiges mehr sehe, unter 98 einiges mehr sehe als unter XP. Zumindest ich als Programmierer.
Also wir empfehlen ja freie Betriebssysteme.
Ich finde ja Vista super.
So klingt die neue Windows Vista-Fehlermeldung. Da muss man sich nicht groß umgewöhnen.
Und das hört man manchmal.
Dachte ich mir, kann man mal spielen so einen Jingle? Echt, habe ich schon?
Ja.
Oh Mist, habe ich auch zentrale Helm gegessen?
Nee, finde ich trotzdem lustig.
Okay, dann ist gut. Soll ich mal zentrale Helm gegessen spielen? Den finde ich auch ganz geil. Nee, ist in Ordnung. Macht mal weiter Bundestrojaner hier. Hier geht es ja um wichtigere Sachen als Jingles.
Naja, ob man das wichtig ist, ist immer so eine Sache. Wenn man es nicht verhindern kann, ist es nicht so wirklich wichtig.
Nein, nein, nein. Noch haben sie nicht mal einen Gesetzentwurf, also möglicherweise.
Aber denken sie setzen das schon ein?
Ja, sie setzen das ein, weil der Verfassungsschutz natürlich rechtlich andere Grundlagen hat. Weil sie einfach von Geheimdiensten her mehr dürfen.
Ist denn schon was bekannt, wo sie es eingesetzt haben oder?
Nee, das haben sie natürlich so deutlich nicht gesagt, aber das Bundesinnenministerium hat zugegeben, dass es einige Einsätze gab. Und irgendwie, dann hat auf so einer Pressekonferenz der Generalbundesanwalt nochmal gesagt, dass seit geraumer Zeit, ich zitiere, erfolgreich mit dem Instrument des heimlichen Abziehens von Daten auf fremden Computern mittels spezieller Software gearbeitet wird. Also sie haben es halt einfach mal zugegeben, aber sicherlich in sehr kleinem Rahmen.
Abziehen können sie wie in Neukölln.
Ja, das fehlt auch wirklich.
Also wie es in den USA mit dieser Website ist, wo sie veröffentlichen, was sie damit wirklich gemacht haben. Weil wenn sie es gemacht haben, dann ist es ja eigentlich wurscht, dann können sie es ja veröffentlichen.
Es soll ja auch verpflichtend werden, dass nachher die Betroffenen, also wenn die Maßnahme abgeschlossen ist, dass die eben dann benachrichtigt werden, wie bei der Telefonüberwachung auch.
Ja, aber es ist ja nicht öffentlich. Sie machen es auch schlicht nicht.
Bei der Telefonüberwachung machen sie es halt schlicht nicht. Wie die Studie von Max-Planck-Institut feststellte, waren die Zahlen ein Drittel oder so was?
Ach, etwa noch weniger.
In einer verschwindend geringen Anzahl der Fälle von Telefonüberwachung machen sie sich hinterher überhaupt die Mühe, tatsächlich mitzuteilen.
Obwohl sie gesetzlich erst überpflichtet sind.
Also in der Regel machen sie das halt nur dann, wenn es halt zum Prozess kommt und das ohnehin offenbar wird.
Ja, weil die Anwälte ja dann die Akten sehen können.
Ein Freund von mir hat das Problem auch schon mal gehabt, der wurde auch von der Polizei telefonisch überwacht, aber der hatte bis heute noch nichts bekommen, keinen schriftlichen...
Wo er weiß, dass er überwacht wurde.
Was ist denn mit dem Telefon so geklickt? Nee, das ist keine Idee. Der war dann bei der Polizei, musste Aussage machen, und da haben sie dann das Turmband vor ihm vorgespielt, von der Aufnahme. Dann haben sie gesagt, hier, schon, hör uns mal. Und dann haben die da dieses Handy-Gespräch mitgeschnitten.
Nee, meinst du, nee, das hat er dir nur erzählt.
Nein, das weiß ich, deswegen war der auch vor Gericht und hat dann schon seine Strafe abbekommen. Gut, der Herr kann natürlich auch lügen, ganz klar. Aber ich glaube ihm halt, von daher.
Warum nicht? Sie müssen es ja eh im Prozess dem Anwalt zur Verfügung stellen. Insofern, warum nicht irgendwie zum Einschüchtern das Verdächtigen benutzen?
Ein gutes Druckmittel, wenn man sagen kann, wir haben ja alles in ihm mitgehört, also können sie mal wieder weiter auspacken.
Ihr Freund nebenan hat schon ausgesagt.
Genau.
So machen sie es ja immer.
Martin, vielen Dank. Gute Nacht. Schöne Nacht noch.
Ihr guckt alle so als... Dann geh ich weiter ans Telefon.
Man muss schon sagen, dass die Ermittlungsbehörden auch nicht blöffen dürfen, wie sie Lust haben. Wir wollen noch mal auf einen Punkt zu sprechen kommen, den wir nicht vergessen wollen, die Zeit uns hier abläuft. Also müssen wir dringend noch über 202C reden.
Ja, genau.
202C. Ja, dringend. Was ist das?
Na, das Anti-Hacker-Tool-Gesetz. Was da jetzt auch groß ist.
STGB 202C, oder was?
Nee, ich glaube, das ist die Strafprozessordnung. Nee, Strafgesetzbuch.
Ja, wonach eben auch unter Strafe gestellt werden soll, Hacker-Tools und Schadsoftware zu besitzen, zu entwickeln, zu vertreiben und so weiter. Abgesehen von den ganzen Problemen, die für so eine IT-Sicherheitsindustrie sich da so auftun, also Virenhersteller und so weiter. Da kann man sich natürlich genauso gut fragen, wie der Staat diesen Trojaner entwickeln möchte, mit Leuten, denen er eigentlich verbietet, sich mit der Thematik überhaupt auseinanderzusetzen und daran zu forschen und zwangsläufig selber auch Hacker-Tools, Schadsoftware und so weiter auf der Platte zu haben, bzw. schon lange solche Software entwickelt zu haben. Das ist sehr widersprüchlich. Und ich meine, wenn der Staat erzählt, unser Bundestrojaner ist hier keine Hacker-Software, weil die macht ja nichts kaputt. Wir dringen nur einen Computer ein und zerstören nichts. Also ist es keine Hacker-Software. Dann kann man diesen Spruch auch auf Leute von uns anwenden, die professionell in der Branche tätig sind und solche Tools auf der Platte haben. Wir machen ja nichts kaputt. Wir decken nur Sicherheitsprobleme auf und so weiter.
Der Hintergrund dieser Hackertool-Verbotsgeschichte ist der folgende. Es gibt die EU Cybercrime Convention, nach der bestimmte Dinge im Computerstrafrecht nur geregelt werden sollen. Eine davon ist unter anderem dieses diskutierte Verbot des Besitzes und der Herstellung und der Verbreitung von allgemein gesprochen Schadsoftware, also Software, die zum einen auch im Computer verwendet werden könnten. In dieser EU-Vorlage steht explizit drin, dass in der Umsetzung dieser Vorlage eine explizite Ausnahme für Forschung, Entwicklung und Tests drin sein soll. Man soll solche Software besitzen und herstellen dürfen, wenn man sie dazu verwendet, um seinen eigenen Rechner zu testen. Sprich, der Besitz von solchen Werkzeugen soll eigentlich nur strafbar sein, wenn sie tatsächlich verwendet wird. Wenn tatsächlich ein Angriff stattfindet, der ohnehin strafrechtlich zu würdigen ist. Schwammig formuliert das. Genau. Die momentane gesetzliche Regelung ist bei weitem ausreichend dafür. In Umsetzung dieser Geschichte ist ein handwerklich extrem unsaures Gesetz entstanden, das, wenn man es wörtlich interpretiert, tatsächlich den Besitz und die Verbreitung und die Herstellung von praktiklichen Computersicherheitswerkzeugen in Deutschland illegalisieren würde.
Das ist aber erst ein Entwurf, also ist ja nicht durch.
Es ist ein Entwurf, der jetzt diskutiert wird. Der ist zum Glück irgendwie vom Bundesrat. Der Bundesrat hat gesagt, ne, müssen wir nochmal in die Ausschüsse. Und momentan wird es halt im Rechtsausschuss beraten. Leute von uns waren da halt auch in den entsprechenden Anhörungen und so weiter. Die Industrie stellt sich da mittlerweile auch auf die Hinterbeine und sagt, das geht aber nicht, weil dann können wir in Deutschland keine Computersicherheitsforschung mehr machen. Also dieses ganze Thema Computersicherheit, Angriff auf Computer von staatlicher Seite, von privater Seite und so weiter, befindet sich da gerade in so einem Gesetzgebungslimbo, wo halt offensichtlich keine klare Linie drin ist. Also es gibt da halt keine Kompetenz in dieser komischen großen Koalition, die halt mal sagen wollen, okay, wir machen das jetzt mal real-weltskompatibel, sondern sie haben da halt irgendwelche komischen Vorstellungen und versuchen die irgendwie durchzupeitschen. Also im Endeffekt der Worst Case wäre halt, Bundestrojaner kommen, Sicherheitsforschung in Deutschland wird verboten. Dann haben wir einen schlampig programmierten Bundestrojaner und keine Sicherheitsindustrie mehr in Deutschland.
Oder sie müssen sich halt immer die Bundestrojaner-Programmierer von sonst wo auf der Welt holen, weil in Deutschland findet ja die Forschung nicht mehr statt.
Genau, Bangalore.
Da wo die größte englischsprachige Programmierer-Community sitzt? Ja, die haben mehr als die Amis.
Wir kommen langsam zum Ende. Haben wir noch einen Punkt, den wir noch haben?
Wir müssen dich noch ein bisschen bejubeln, Holgi.
Jubeln!
Ja, wir müssen dich noch ein bisschen bejubeln.
Ne, das müssen wir nicht.
Doch, unbedingt. Wir müssen nämlich unseren Hörern mal eine ganz schlimme Mitteilung machen. Ich bringe das nicht über die Lippen.
Ich bringe das nicht über die Lippen. Chaosradio 122, also diese Sendung hier, ist meine letzte Sendung, also mein letztes Chaosradio. Denn die Karawane zieht weiter. Neue Aufgaben treiben mich an neue Gestade. Ich werde in einer anderen Stadt einen weiteren Job übernehmen. Und dieser Job, also in Frankfurt am Main, um genau zu sein. Und dieser Beruf, diese Aufgabe, dieser Job, den ich da übernehme, der verhindert es sowohl logistisch als auch inhaltlich, dass ich mich am letzten Mittwoch im Monat hier in Potsdam versammle, um mit euch zusammen oder wer auch immer vom Club dann da ist, um das Chaosradio zu machen, das Chaosradio weiter zu machen. Das heißt, ich verabschiede mich nach sieben Jahren. Und wer meckert dann die Nazis an? Na, von denen könnt ihr mir die Telefonnummern schicken, dann komme ich da rum. Dann treffe ich mich mit denen alleine und unbewaffnet und dann gucken wir mal, wie hart die Jungs sind.
Dann könntest du deine Sendung mit der Chaosradio-Sendung zusammen schalten.
Darum die Sendung zusammenlegen.
Ja, ich meine, wir haben ihm auch schon vorgeschlagen, dass er einfach Chaosradio sozusagen charmtelefonisch moderiert und wir uns dann einfach die Hörer teilen. Du kriegst dann so ein paar Brandenburger Nazis rübergeschaltet und du kriegst...
Nein, ich will ihn noch sehen.
Ich schalt so ein paar hessische Unionsmitglieder.
Genau, wir kriegen so ein paar hessische Unionsmitglieder und dann machen wir eine schöne Videokonferenz. Weil 2007 soll das doch wohl hinzukriegen sein, oder nicht?
Du meinst, wir sollten immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat eine Leitung legen und das Chaosradio bundesweit verbreiten, sozusagen?
Ja, da sind wir schwer dafür.
Da sind wir schwer dafür. Das ist gar nicht mal so eine schlechte Idee. Ja sagen kann ich dazu nicht, weil ich nicht die Hoheit über die Leitung, also über dieses ARD-Leitungsnetz habe. Aber was ich machen werde, ist, ich werde meinen beiden Chefs, nämlich dem hier und dem beim hessischen Rundfunk, genau das vorschlagen. Dann habt ihr nur das Problem, dass ihr hier die erste Stunde, weil in Frankfurt meine Sendung um 23 Uhr immer erst anfängt, dass ihr hier die erste Stunde irgendwie überbrücken müsst.
Ein paar Nazis beschimpfen müssen, das kriegen wir schon hin.
Dann könnt ihr ja sowas machen wie, weiß ich nicht, die Windows-Hotline verarschen.
Hörerservice heißt das doch?
Hörerservice, genau Hörerservice heißt das. Ja, es war schön. Also es waren so ziemlich genau sieben Jahre. Aber ich hab im Februar 2000 angefangen. Und ich mach das auch nicht gern. Danke für alles, danke für die schöne Zeit. Vielleicht hören wir uns dann ja doch nochmal wieder. Ich probier das, ich werd das auf jeden Fall vorschlagen.
Ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass es irgendeinen anderen Moderator gibt, der so...
Den gab's ja auch schon mal, ne? Zwischenzeitig, wenn ich da mal keine Zeit hatte, hat der Kollege Max von Malotky das gemacht.
Ja, das ist auch als Einspringen gut, aber das ist halt irgendwie die perfekte Kombination. Wir erwarten doch einige Einträge im Wiki von euch, dass ihr auch mal was zu sagt.
Danke schön.
Und wenn ihr zufällig aus dem Sendegebiet des Hessischen Rundfunks zuhört, dann wisst ihr, wir würden eure Postkarten schicken.
Es geht weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf im Studio für Abschieden sich, Constanze, Thorsten, Frank und Holgi.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Tschüss.